Three four,
three,
two,
one.
Yeah.
And we're live gentlemen.
What's up?
What's going on again?
What's happening?
Happy to be here man.
Happy to have you here man.
Thanks.
You are the only guy right now that I know of that is fighting at the highest
level in three combat sports.
Correct?
MMA,
Moy,
Thai and kickboxing.
That's fucking crazy.
Thanks man.
Keep your head together.
I Dunno.
Like last time warming up in Rome,
actually it was the first time like warming up for a kickbox.
If I threw a spinning back,
I was it,
I'd better not do that shit.
Back.
Elbows,
window and to kickbox.
You can do a spinning back fist though,
right?
Did,
which I learned it.
Two of them in my last five.
Do you see the,
what's happening lately where a lot of guys are hitting foreheads with their
arms snapping their arm page?
Did it?
Um,
uh,
obviously,
who else did it recently?
Paul Felder did it.
A couple of guys have done it.
They spin and you,
you catch foreheads and that is not a good combination,
I feel.
I feel like the kickboxing glove protects you a little bit more than that.
Probably does four ounce,
10 ounce.
There's a,
there's a little bit of cushion there that might protect you a little more.
Yeah,
it's still,
I don't know,
it's still something that,
you know when they first started fighting kickboxing he was like,
I don't know him and like be careful with it because I would like kind of catch
like the middle of my arm.
You know,
it's a little,
it's a little different than the spinning elbow,
which is in my opinion,
a lot more safer it to throw.
Now what happens if you throw a spinning back fist and kickboxing and you really
kind of catch them with like the meat above the elbow.
It's illegal.
It's legal or illegal.
You're only about here.
No,
you have to in based on in whether its glory or it's k one or it's a Bella tour.
It has to be with the back knuckle back of the pad of that love.
You can't be the side and that'll be the hammer fist.
That is illegal.
That's weird.
You'll get a point deduct it.
And if you cause more damage than the f you might go DQ.
Get the cute,
yeah.
When Sato knocked out Joe and that Bella tour fight,
if you watch it,
it was a hammer fist and there was a lot of talk about whether it was legal or
illegal,
but it wasn't a back fist.
It was a hammer fist.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's not interesting.
It's illegal per Iska and most governing bodies.
So when Joe Schilling in that kickboxing fight,
when they first saw,
because they spun it because he landed with the back of the hand or the side of
the hand,
it's actually illegal.
It's considered a foul.
Yeah.
Did anybody bring it up?
They mentioned it,
but I think at that time Joe had come off of that Simon situation with lion
fight and he was like,
ah,
move on.
You know?
Right.
You know,
I got knocked out.
It is what it is,
you know?
So he didn't make a big deal about it.
That dude his fucking hard.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And Joe,
so reckless,
he's so aggressive.
You know,
like he,
he has these moments of like extreme emotion where he's just,
and that dude,
he wanted to knock that dude out so bad after he got knocked out in the MMA
fight.
He wanted to knock him out in his rules.
And I think that I think is what you saw with Cody this weekend.
Too much emotion.
One fight.
Yeah man.
We were talking about that and watching the replays,
like you could see in his face that every shot he was trying to knock them out
with.
As soon as I saw him walk,
I mean not walk out.
I said he looked like a walking out as soon as the bell rung.
I was like,
he just did it.
He looked a little stiff.
Yeah.
You know,
and I was hoping he would shake it off,
get in the rhythm,
like land,
a couple jabs,
just like,
you know,
we were working on,
when I spar with them a couple of times leading up to the TJ fight,
I'll go up to Alpha male to do my wrestling.
And a lot of my grappling,
um,
you know,
they have so many hundred 3,545 pounders up there that only an hour and half
away drive.
Right.
It only makes sense to go up there and exchange knowledge.
So you know,
as soon as I saw him walk out and started the fight,
I was like,
I hope she just,
he just shakes it off and like gets into his,
his groove.
Like when he fought dom,
that was artwork that was,
that was incredible.
He just let him come to him and I was hoping that was what was his game plan,
knock his fucking ass out.
He wanted to use more wrestling from what a,
we were talking to Danny and all those guys about it.
He wanted to use more wrestling and definitely a lot of kicks.
Yeah.
He,
he wanted to kick up a little bit as well,
but he also wanted to just do the same thing to what he did to dom.
You know,
just kind of like peace them up.
And I mean considering the last fight,
he almost finish him in the first round.
Right.
When they first fought,
he was like,
I can,
I can do this,
I can finish this guy.
I think he could finish anybody.
Yeah.
But it's,
he's got to go about it the right way.
And I thought he was going about it the right way initially with the kicks.
And I was like,
look,
even if these are just landing on the arms,
like these are going to soften TJ up.
The other brutal,
he was throwing some brutal kicks it and it was a totally different thing.
He was a,
he was adding a whole different aspect to the fight and he did in the first part
and it,
it wasn't,
uh,
it,
when he started throwing the kicks,
I was like,
yeah,
there's the game plan.
I see what I see what's going on.
Beautiful.
And then when he pointed to the ground and he was like,
yes,
you couldn't touch me.
I'm like,
oh,
he's starting to get in this rhythm.
But that's what I hate about immediate rematches after knock out.
It's just,
it's still in your head.
It's just the confidence level,
the anger,
the emotion.
Like,
you know,
Henry two,
three years between his fight with Dj,
where he got finished in the first round,
right.
More fights,
fighting some other people.
Uh,
he was a different human.
Absolutely.
But if he had fought DJ the very next fight,
who knows how that goes,
right?
It was,
that would be hard to sell less.
Henry was the champion and Dj took the crown from him.
This was the whole idea was that,
you know,
Cody had beat dom Cody was the champ and that Cody was defending the honor of
Alpha male and Tj was this snake in the grass they were going to put away.
That was the whole idea behind the ultimate fighter.
And there was just so,
I don't think there's ever been a fight other than maybe Ronda and Miesha that
had more emotion,
just more,
you know,
bad blood by the Rondon Ameesha thing might've been worse.
It's,
people don't remember how hated Rhonda was after that Meesha fight,
cause she wouldn't shake me.
She's hand like me.
She tried to shake your hand and Ron was like,
bitch could,
I didn't just walk away.
And everybody's like,
whoa.
And like why was interviewing her?
It was just a blue,
like the whole audience was booing those emotional fights.
They're so compelling to watch,
but man,
they're so fraught with peril for the fighters.
Absolutely.
If you look at his face,
his kid has 50 fights.
Yes.
50 fights.
Amateur Muay Thai,
MMA,
kickboxing back to a junior.
The only scars you're going to see on his face are from a fight where he fought
Damien early,
whose brother had that was in line fight.
That was a lion fight.
I saw that fight.
Yeah,
I was very angry.
He was very,
he wanted to put him away.
I dropped him twice once because it,
Gaston was a rising star in line fight at the time and the family,
they're the earliest,
the Chasse Danes,
and everything's cool now,
but at the time the parents were very aggressive online towards guest on.
They were like,
well,
he parents where they won't fight,
he won't fight our boy.
Well,
one,
you're not even in his weight class,
you know,
and then you know,
they said,
oh,
we can make the wait.
So,
okay,
if you make the weight will take the fight.
And they made the way they made the weight.
But it was the one,
and I've said it sense does anything to Eddie and Eddie who?
Eddie episode,
my one of my teammates,
we've been trained together for what,
like five years now?
Yeah.
And what was the problem with them?
They fought Damien and Eddie fought her 155 pounds,
which is what Eddie and they both fight it that way.
Then he wants to come down to fight me.
But Eddie landed in legal elbow in the back of the neck.
It wasn't,
it didn't seem like it was that hard,
but it ended the fight.
And Eddie got the cute and then they're just talking mad shit saying,
Oh,
you know,
you want it.
You did that on purpose.
And like Eddie,
if you meet Eddie,
you'd be like,
he's the coolest guy ever.
He's a smooth,
silky,
smooth,
amazing.
It seems so chill in there and it just,
just really knows how to pace himself and it just extend his energy perfectly.
I mean,
really interesting fighter to watch.
He's,
he's my favorite people to work with.
Like trains.
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
he's such,
uh,
any such an amazing who would be now and in the best part is,
is that guest on hated it.
I hated it.
Hated it.
Was this pre pre Braids Eddie?
Uh,
yeah.
And so growing up as an amateur Eddie,
Eddie started what,
like two years after that?
About two years after I did.
And you know,
I always like shake his hand and stuff like that when I saw him,
but we,
they camp that he was from his coach,
hated me.
Did not like me at all.
Yeah.
And uh,
so Gaston was fighting in San Francisco and it was the first time the gas don't
ever got knocked out and he got knocked out and he was supposed to,
you know,
there's,
and Gaston at the time,
locally in the bay area,
he was the guy,
you know,
the amateur kid,
he's a star.
Everybody loves him.
Years old,
beating everybody,
fighting.
Anybody,
anybody in any way class from,
you know,
one 30,
one 37 to one form 50.
I'll fight anybody.
I didn't care.
I was just trying to get the experience the first two years of,
of my junior career and not so much the first year I fought as a junior,
I beat pretty much every,
everybody my age and back then the rules were like,
if you're under 16 you can't,
if you're under 18 you're a junior here.
Get me in trouble man.
So we,
we just fake my,
my birth and my dad had my birth certificate often.
Yeah.
So it was April 18 two years before that I was 18 I haven't find adults early.
People do that.
That's dope.
Nobody would fight him.
He couldn't find him.
He knew what he was doing that or he'd beat everybody junior.
So we said,
okay.
So we made an 18 and he fought and he got and he got knocked out.
Just he cut too much weight for a fight in it.
You know,
you go as you,
as you learned,
he cut down to 37 and,
and it was a little to walk around with weight.
Well the thing is I was planning on fighting.
So what was the camp that were fine?
My issue,
my issue.
So we're fighting,
we're supposed to fight at one 42 which I was fine with and at the time I
probably could've made one,
one 35 but the week of is like,
Hey,
your opponent dropped out,
his teammate will fight you the whole fight.
You one 37.
Oh yeah.
And you know,
going from extra pounds is a lot,
but going from one 40.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was like walking on one 49 going like another 12 pounds at that age.
I was like 18 I wasn't,
I didn't do it right.
I was just like,
it just didn't work out for me.
So he got caught and uh,
I was winning the fight.
Absolutely.
It's one of the fight destroying.
I mean,
and again,
this guy,
I think he works at Walmart now.
Now that's not a bullshit.
This is great kid power right hand cause respect to Walmart,
no disrespect.
But he got caught and in between rounds I could see it.
It was like a deer in headlight.
He just guessed on was on autopilot.
He was winning,
but he wasn't there.
So he gets caught.
He gets dropped and literally Eddie's camp was just swarmed the ring screaming
and yelling guest ons out.
And I remember clearly seeing Eddie and that guy coronary like you know,
just like,
yeah and like he was just part of the camp doing what everybody,
all his friends were doing.
And since then I was like,
oh,
I hate that.
We all,
we all,
we all hated the camp.
We all hated Eddie.
And then one of one of our team,
my teammates fought Eddie,
same thing but cut.
He thought a Brooks Brooks cut them right on top of the head.
Brooks,
he had to have a staples and everything and same thing.
They were just like treating us like they were the shit.
And I was like,
fuck these guys man.
Emotions involved in camps.
I mean it's,
it's such a wasted thing.
It doesn't,
it's definitely bad for the fighters because it creates this added element.
Like fighting is hard enough as it is.
But when you add all this hate and disdain,
the only thing he could potentially do is if you don't have a good work ethic,
which obviously you do,
it'll get you up
some.
Do you remember when Buster Douglas fought Mike Tyson when buster Douglas was a
42 to one underdog,
but everybody knew buster had talent,
but he was like a lazy guy.
Then his mom died and when his mom died,
he just made a decision.
He was like,
fuck this,
you know,
he was hurting.
He was in pain and he's like,
I'm going to train like a wild animal for this fight.
I'm going to train like I've never trained before.
I'm going to,
I'm going to train like a real world champion,
and he came out there Jabin and Hook it off the jab and everybody's like,
what the fuck is going on with the combination that he knocked Tyson out with
was like,
Holy Shit.
Well,
only achieved those heights again.
Only fight I've ever bet on my entire life was that fight.
You bet on ties in Asia,
but 500 to win 50 bucks,
it's 50 free dollars.
Crazy emotions are never good.
I mean,
that's like a rare time where emotions work good because it got a lazy guy to
the gym to train like a real professional.
Yep.
And the thing with Eddie is that without question,
Eddie is the glue that holds our team together.
Here's the best thing that ever happened to our gym because he's crazy.
His Ego,
he doesn't like,
his ego is just like not he's,
he'll just do whatever.
He's like,
Hey,
you want to work?
You want to do this?
What do you,
what?
What do you want to do?
He's not,
there's no like we're both Alpha males and CSA,
you know,
like,
yeah,
well he's like,
Hey,
what do you want to do man?
You want to run?
You want to work?
Those are the guys that grow,
man.
The guys that grow are the guys to help just chill out and help our team girls
so much.
When Eddie came to me,
he basically like we literally,
same thing happened with a guest on is that because Gaston was a little prick
when I met him too.
But Eddie,
he,
and he'll admit it.
He was like,
you know,
he was just around the wrong people.
I watched him fight and his last amateur fight and I hated him and I was rooting
for him to lose.
I was literally sitting in the back being a hater going,
oh,
this is awesome.
And he started losing a fight.
He blew his knee out and he started losing.
And while the fight was happening,
I started rooting for him and I hated him.
But his heart and his spirit was the first I ever saw one of those towns kids
ever saw.
I blew his knee out,
blew his ACL,
kept fighting through the whole fight.
It was one most impressive performance I've ever seen.
After the fight,
I went back into the locker room.
He was by himself crying.
His coach wasn't there.
He has a team left cause he,
he,
you know,
he was undefeated champion,
world champion,
amateur world champion.
Like he had racked up a ton of fights and you know,
the team,
his team was behind him because he was winning.
But then he loses against the guy that he had beat him before.
Yup.
And then his team was gone and I went back and I told him,
I said,
listen,
this probably doesn't mean much to you.
I said,
but I want to tell you that I am more impressed with you and losing this fight
and what I saw from you than in any
time else that you showboated you won.
You destroy people,
the heart you displayed.
You are one of the best fighters I've ever seen in my life.
Three months later he hit me up,
brought ice cream,
came to CSA and he said,
hey,
can I train here?
Brought ice cream,
brought ice cream.
I saw,
I saw him walked in with his fucking answering.
I was like,
what is going on right now?
Guests die.
Is he here guest Don King?
No you did.
No.
And he said,
Eddie trains here.
I'm leaving because I'm gone.
How long did it take you to warm up to him?
We spar ones and you know,
Karen had a real talk with me.
He's like,
listen man,
I'm,
you know,
I'm the head coach here and like,
um,
your,
your dad like relax,
I know what I'm doing.
When have I failed you?
You know,
I'm telling you this,
you know,
if he,
if he's,
if he's who he,
we think he is or we thought he was,
you know,
like I'll,
I'll know you'll leave,
but you got to give them the opportunity and when he saying that he's telling
the truth,
I was his legal guardian at the time when he threatened to leave.
The first question on my mouth was,
are you going to leave the gym or are you going to leave my house?
But you live there too.
So he was living with me.
I said,
so it's gotta be weird if you're training somewhere else.
How old were you then?
15 I became a no,
Guardian went when it came,
I was maybe 18.
Nobody?
No,
yeah.
Became his,
his parents moved back to Peru and I became his legal guardian so he could
finish school here in the u s and he came to live with me and I put them,
put them into college and all that.
Yeah.
Year before that.
That's a tight relationship.
A year before that
commuting.
So I had,
I was trying to affair tax mountain view,
uh,
at the time and I was coaching there and he was coaching there every couple of
days.
And then,
you know,
we,
2008 happened South Korea if ma,
uh,
he was the coach for the US National Moitai team and you know,
we just,
we just clicked.
We were just like,
you know,
he w
when I,
when I met him at,
at Fairtex,
I was teaching,
I was hitting a heavy bag.
He came walking up to me,
he was like,
he's 14,
15,
he's got his picture on the front window at Fairtex mountain view.
So He's,
you know,
cause he's a good looking kid.
He was a surfer and modeling and all that.
So he walks up and he rolls up.
He rolls up his shorts next to me.
He goes,
who are you man?
And I'm like,
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm carrying him.
He goes,
okay.
what do you do here?
I was like,
I teach.
He goes,
I never see you here before Johnson ons,
my coach,
he starts kicking the bag,
kicking the back.
I'm like,
oh,
okay,
cool.
All right,
good to know.
So then Johnson on couldn't coach the national team in 2008 and Korea.
So as a fair tax coach,
they asked me if I wanted to go.
I said,
yeah.
So I get onto the plane on my way to Korea for the world championships and I see
this thing connection and they can action that.
The connection,
the connection.
I was like,
and I see here and I see this and I see this little fuck it.
I'm like,
Oh God,
I hate this kid and I couldn't stand him.
And so we get there and I'm like,
he's going to get murdered and I'm happy.
I'm glad he's going to go,
but he's going to learn a lesson.
He's a valuable lesson.
I didn't cut.
Yeah at the
time and I've,
I
was fighting the returner returning two time gold medalist that if my on my
first ever,
that was my first grown ass man,
his when he made his amateur debut at the world championships against the
returning champion who was like,
it was Becca.
Stan was a of standing kid like really,
really good.
Probably 80 fights.
He was 17 he was 17 about to make the jump into a class the next year.
So I'm literally,
I'm writing out his parent's name and phone number so I can call them after this
children's,
your amateur debut?
Pretty much,
yeah.
Amateur debut.
I was against an amateur world champion at the world championships.
He was finance.
Yes it was.
It was crazy.
It was the,
I didn't up,
I didn't even know.
I didn't even know cause I was just going through,
I was like,
I'm just going to my,
and my mind,
I was going to go in there and fuck this kid up even though he was way taller
than me and like I wasn't cutting away at the time.
These,
these guys cut weight,
they take,
you know,
all those countries that eastern bloc,
they take it very seriously because if you get a gold medal there,
you're pretty much set for life.
Yeah.
More types.
Huge internationally.
Most people don't understand it at that time.
2008,
2009,
it's kind of the dark era of International Moyie Thai here in America.
The United States,
we tie federation,
which is kind of like the Olympic,
the US Olympic Committee,
cause it's not an Olympic sport yet.
It was literally who can afford to go.
There was no government funding.
There's no uh,
there was no selection process and literally we had a team of six people.
Yeah,
right.
Thailand's got 40.
Russia's got 50 people.
We went,
there were six people.
Um,
and uh,
Anthony Lin,
who was the president of the fair tax USA,
was the founder of USM.
F He was the poster boy at Fairtex just as a kid.
And he didn't really,
he didn't have any fight shit.
He's just a good looking kid that kicked really well.
So that will take them over there and be good experience for them.
The whole time I'm like,
this kid is going to get fucking murder.
No Way.
I mean,
I had no idea what I was walking into.
I had a few smokers,
I had to go.
He goes out.
I wanted him to tell him,
don't go ahead though.
I go out there,
I just like get hit.
And I was like,
Holy Shit,
this guy hits like a man.
It's really hard.
But I was just,
I just didn't care.
I just went in there and they gave it all I had.
I really did.
And I was really disappointed in my performance because I really truly believed
I was going to win the fight.
I went in there to win even though I had no,
not,
not much experience.
I didn't have 80,
80 fights as he did.
I had zero.
I had maybe a couple of smokers,
uh,
two amateur fights when I was like 12 and 13 but that's about it.
And one boxing fight.
But that was it.
This guy had 80 and a lot of them were probably professional fights.
Absolutely.
There's no such thing as amateur in white tie.
And in Europe like I mean,
yeah they consider it like B class,
but they still fight without shinguards.
They still do all this and like when they go in there,
they,
they're going in there to win and I thought,
I mean I lost,
I knew I had lost the fight but I lost a split decision.
It was crazy.
Crazy.
It's to go in there and like,
I mean I knew something was up when I saw my matchup was like an ounce and this
guys,
he didn't have his full name.
They also,
they only had his first name.
I was like,
they know this guy.
I was say didn't,
it was a guest on the line is against what was the oil back or something like
that.
And so whatever happened to him,
I think we saw him the next year.
The next year he went into like a doll class.
But it was like,
so there's [inaudible] and there's a class eight classes where most of the pros
go,
right.
He went straight into a class after fighting me.
His coach beat the shit out of him after losing a through witness split decision
against me,
just beat him distraught in front of us and the light cause he heard because he
heard I was,
that was only like my third fight or like my amateur debut.
He was like,
you know Americans were in really beat him in front of you.
Yeah.
Also beat,
just slap the shit out of him.
Like one of the worst things I've ever seen.
Yeah.
It's very,
very different over there and in the fight the crowd got behind guest on because
he was doing very dynamic things.
He was,
and that was really small too.
I was only like,
what,
five,
four.
At the time this guy was like five 11 and in between rounds my light switch went
off with him because literally I go in between rounds and I go,
I go look over there.
I said,
look,
this is the the previous world champion.
I said,
you are going toe to toe with him.
you,
he is tired.
And he looks up at me.
He goes,
you guys not goes.
I'm not tired.
Americans don't get tired.
I'm like,
well number one,
calm down.
You're Peruvian.
Okay.
Take it easy.
Uh,
number two,
you're the cutest thing ever.
I love you to death.
Uh,
and from that moment on,
this kid has literally been my son and what sealed it for me is while we were
backstage,
this kid was getting beat within an inch of his life by his coach,
guest on takes off his jersey,
walks over and interrupts the beating and gives his Jersey because that's kind
of customary to give exchange jerseys and erupted the beading.
Yeah.
How long is this meeting going on for?
So they walked off,
he wasn't even like,
it's his team had kind of left them to this coach has walked him back and just
like start slapping the shit out of him.
And then I stopped it and I was like,
how long was he slapping him for?
Well,
like the walk back was like,
well,
like,
like 10 minutes for 10.
Just berating them.
Yeah,
it,
it's bad.
Everybody was like,
Oh shit.
What's going on over there?
Yeah.
It's not the best way to motivate someone.
Definitely.
Now,
he won.
He Won.
He won the whole tournament.
He wanted,
yeah,
he took all those hours.
Probably his toughest fight though.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the,
the crazy thing about that is this,
you know,
in America,
people don't even understand that Moy could be that big somewhere else.
That it could be that important to people.
You know,
it's more ties a mystery to me in the sense that I just don't understand why it
never caught on.
I really don't get it.
I think it's part of,
it's the music part of,
it's the,
the,
the ritual
part of it is just the way MMA blew up.
I mean,
if you look at that and go through all the why crew and everything in Europe
eat,
if it's Moitai Yaffe is kickboxing.
No,
but if it's Moyie Thai,
yeah,
but like he was the first.
It literally,
he would,
he was the first junior that the u s ever sent to the world championships ever.
He was by himself and he was the only junior ever.
Today there are 16 juniors fighting in Thailand at the junior world
championships.
They went eight and Oh,
today.
Yeah.
Some momentum.
A huge momentum right now.
Literally not in the public.
Not so it's in the fighters themselves.
Yes.
It's not publicly known,
but right now the best junior team at the junior world championships is the
United States.
Have you thought about that though?
Why is that?
Like why?
How come no one can figure out a way to make it exciting or make it,
put it on television and let people know like,
Hey,
this is probably one of the most dynamic cotton that's definitely one of the
most dynamic combat sports in the world next to MMA.
Um,
a lot of it has to do with money.
It's,
it's promoters will come in and they will be the next best thing.
Lion fight.
Got It right the most and then they lost the access TV deal.
What happened with them?
Um,
for you,
if you asked line fight,
they lost the deal because access TV wanted too much commitment.
If you ask,
ask the STV lion,
I was canceling too many shows.
It depends on who you ask,
but what are they on?
Like ESPN three or some shit.
No flow elite combat is street.
Nobody knows about it.
Like,
yeah.
Which is hard to get people to watch it on access TV.
I mean,
access TV is a fairly fringe cable channel.
Absolutely.
Some,
it's again,
much like MMA.
I mean,
it was the right place,
right time,
right recipe,
ultimate fighter on the right night and great fight at the end and all of a
sudden everybody's talking about it.
You know,
the story better than anybody.
That hasn't happened from [inaudible] and it's,
and it's a shame and I'd been around it now,
uh,
coached Miriam,
Kevin,
you know,
these guys have carried more,
we tie in their shoulder for years.
Nobody knew who it was.
How does bell tours,
kickboxing ratings do?
It does.
Honestly.
I mean it,
it does as well as maybe a two year old rerun of cops,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
You know,
it does,
it does better than glory did.
Well,
this is what,
well,
that's weird,
right?
Yeah.
Why?
Why does it do better than glory?
Um,
I think just because a torn,
it ties to the Bella tour name.
So Joe Schilling has decided no more kickboxing.
He's,
he's no more and more time.
He's doing it for financial reasons and he's in his thirties I think you
probably realize is like how many years you have left.
Five,
six years left.
Maybe if everything goes great and nothing gets blown out,
you know,
and he's just decided,
that's a,
that bothers me.
It me too.
It's a labor of love for Scott Coker.
Literally.
He's convinced paramount
to keep it going because they believe in him.
He's doing this.
He started off with kickbox exactly because he started out with a strike strike
force was originally kickbox and k one it does bothers me.
I just don't,
I don't get it.
You know,
I watch,
I'm a big fan of boxing.
I love boxing,
but it's not as fun.
More ties,
more fun to watch.
It's more exciting.
And I used to love watching line fight.
I was so happy when it was on.
I have all of them recorded on my Dvr,
you know,
and I'm now good luck trying to find Moitai on TV they had,
it's tough.
It's tough.
I mean,
not to toot our horn,
but I mean,
when it comes to Moitai,
we're the biggest gym in North America and we have the most active fighters and
it's hard to get my people where they need to be.
There are other shows step up,
you know,
triumphant,
uh,
is on fight pass.
That's a great show.
Friday night fights is trying.
Lion fight is still around,
you know,
I'll always support lion fight for,
hell,
we help build that brand to the best as we could.
Um,
but right now,
uh,
regionally,
Dennis Warner in,
so cal is always going to have shows triumphant Good Friday night fights as good
glory.
You know,
they're,
they're not really behind American talent yet.
They're just,
they're just not.
Well,
the problem is they do a lot of shows in Europe and these European fighters are
extremely popular over there.
Absolutely.
I mean,
if they had their druthers,
they would do Badr Hari every weekend.
Absolutely.
And that's what they would do.
You know what I mean?
That guy sells out arenas.
It's Kinda crazy scary.
Jesus Christ.
We're just playing a video the other day,
slapping some a hotel,
a desk person walked behind the desk and smack this guy and then
he gets arrested for breaking a Guy Shin stomping a Guy Shin in half.
He's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean he's like a very odd combination of a,
of lethal fighter and a thug.
He's both for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
And he wants you to know,
you know,
what mood is he in today?
Which ones?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
he's the most compelling story right now.
And uh,
in European kickboxing.
Yeah,
for sure.
Without question.
They announced collusion to and they didn't even put his image up and all of a
sudden people are excited just because of him and Rico's first.
Are they supposed to fight again?
Is that what's going to happen?
Rico Verhoeven in him,
I think that's the plan.
That's where they're going now.
He broke his arm in that first fight.
Did they know how,
was that a preexisting injury or is it just something that happened in the
middle of a scramble?
It,
it looked to me blocking a Kik is what it looked like to me.
And again,
if you block a kick with the illness is not going to take that.
It's just not done it right.
You know,
you need to reinforce the block.
Rico is a big dude,
so he shoots you arm.
Rico's unusual too.
And he's a big guy,
but he fights very technically and he's got great cardio and moves really well.
Yeah,
man.
Narratively,
well his gas tank is fantastic for a bit.
For a big guy.
Definitely.
Yeah.
When he got hurt bad against Jamal Benson deek and you're like,
Whoa,
like this,
look,
this is not look good.
Then he came back and stopped them motherfuckers.
The real deal.
Definitely.
He's,
he's a beast.
But again,
America,
good guy could go to Walmart.
Nobody knows who the fuck he is.
Wander around.
It's one of the best heavyweight kickboxers of all time.
Literally nobody knows who he is.
It's strange,
you know,
without,
without question.
Yeah.
Now when you were training with Cody,
um,
when you were over at team Alpha Male,
what does the coaching like?
Like,
how are they,
how are they doing rounds with him?
Uh,
while he was doing his sparring separately,
they brought us,
they brought me in,
Eddie up just to spar with him.
Uh,
who is,
who was coaching him?
Uh,
Danny and Danny Castillo.
Chris Holdsworth.
So they were essentially his coaches that were coaching him.
Okay.
And so when you were working with him,
were they saying,
hey,
we want to really work on it?
Certain things or would they just letting you do your thing?
Are they asking you to I was being,
I go up there and like I said,
I go grapple.
So I was trying to be a good giving him good luck,
skim the switches,
GIM.
Then like that TJ shoulder move type.
Did you practice that stuff or did you not?
I just,
I just been one of those guys like Karen ever since I started with Koreans like,
and I've had to help somebody like given books and it's been that guy and I've
been good at it.
Practice t J's looks or did you just kind of know how to do it?
I always switch regardless and like at this,
one of my favorite things to do just offensively and defensively.
I love switching.
Did you have a traditional martial arts background?
Did you start out with traditional martial?
I started with white tie,
which started with Morton.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
Some the best guys.
You know,
it's interesting now that the switching thing has become almost like a standard
thing like with Tj.
Do you never know what he's doing.
You don't,
I mean he doesn't have like I'll revert back to stance.
He might stand south Paul.
He might stand orthodox and he can do both equally well.
Yeah.
Well I'm naturally either ride with my,
where my left hand naturally,
but I stand orthologs I served for I skate.
Orthox well there's a lot of people,
I mean that was what,
uh,
Eddie fuck used to or manual steward rather used to teach guys to do that.
He would take a guy who was right handed and make them fight.
Southpaws like you want that lead hand to be your most coordinated hand.
Yeah,
but we have,
we have pat sessions that I'll just stand softball at the whole time and I have
no problem with it.
I,
I in fact love spine softball and I love just switching.
Do you feel like you're straight left hand has as much power as a straight right
hand?
Sometimes.
Even more.
Really.
Sometimes even more.
Yeah.
I feel,
I feel like I have power of,
of both hands.
Oh.
Almost equally.
Just depends on the angle and where I'm catching it as a trial to try to catch
people at the same time as they're trying to get away from my right hand.
I'll switch stances and aggressively switched into,
into the,
uh,
that left hand and they get a power hand and they think they're getting away
from my power him.
But really there were walking into it and I make him switch into it.
Ah,
yeah.
Now,
so when you were working with Cody,
did they,
did they have any requests that they say,
Hey,
this is what code is trying to work on?
You know,
it just really just,
I was just switching a lot of trying to get him that,
that switch left that switch hook that he got caught with last time and I was
trying to just be a good teammate and you give him head kicks in that kind of
movement and he was doing fairly well,
um,
blocking kicks coming back,
uh,
and trying to wrestle more.
But because I had,
I think they were talking about that was one thing that he lacked in the first
fight.
Not Wrestling him enough.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well what,
what happens Saturday was definitely not the game plan.
You're not,
you could,
you could see it was it,
it wasn't anything like he sparred and it wasn't anything like he trained,
I think emotion absolutely took over.
Yeah.
Well,
so what was their game plan?
I think just pieced him up,
get him,
you know,
catch him like the first round,
but actually finish the fight.
I think that would have been more than obviously kick him a lot and just get him
to walk into something.
Try to wrestle him a little bit in there too.
I think,
I think Tj came out really smart as well though.
Well,
TJ throws himself into the fire too.
He's,
he's not,
he does not play it safe game.
Yeah.
Oh,
he didn't,
he did not Saturday.
And I,
and I think that,
I think that he was probably a little surprised by how,
um,
just by how unsafe Cody was so early.
Like,
I mean,
that exchange at the end,
I mean it's the Cody,
I mean Tj is just blocking and looking and going.
He is just going for broke,
right.
Everything he's throwing.
Yeah.
And we,
when we were watching the replays,
you could clearly see that Cody's path was wider and there's more strain.
And then Tj was more loose and he got there quicker,
you know,
and they'll knock down the first knocked down when he tagged me the right hand.
That was really where it came from.
They're both throwing at the same time.
But TJ was also doing a better job of getting his head offline.
And the thing is like,
t Jay's relationship with Duane Ludwig is very unusual.
It's like,
those guys are like glue.
I mean they're,
they're fucking stuck together.
And Dwayne is a maniac.
You know,
Dwayne,
I know Duane,
I've known Dwayne a long time.
We are friends and when we coached against each other that the ultimate fighter,
he literally in the parking lot,
it reminded me that he had the fastest knockout in UFC history because he was
fucking pissed.
Like he,
he,
he's just one of those guys that who's pissed about what,
just because we were trying to,
he had a training practice that he invited all of Henry's guys too,
but Henry couldn't come.
And I was like,
well,
I'm going to have Johnson on come in and Joe can't come.
And he's like,
hey listen,
I'm going to whip my dick out right now.
I'm going to remind you,
I've got the fastest knockout in UFC history,
so you better calm down boy.
And I'm like,
well,
okay.
But so he's very emotional.
He's very focused and he's very dedicated to Tj.
So I'm agreeing with you on that.
But he will go zero like that.
Oh yeah.
Doing,
it's crazy as fuck.
I know very,
very well.
But what I'm saying is that Duane is obsessed with,
with t J's performance and with Tj is improvement.
When TJ first beat Hanan Barao Dwayne sat down with me.
We sat down,
we had lunch together that day and he was just,
and it was a fucking big underdog.
I mean Hanan Barao was thought to be the best pound for pound fighter if not
number one,
certainly number two,
same way he did that,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
Also,
the way he did it,
he came out so loose like he was sparring.
He came out like,
you know,
like the touch gloves,
like he was going to do a sparring session and it looked like a guy sparred with
a fucking hundred rounds.
It wasn't,
there was no tension to him.
It was very loose.
He really loves that Shit.
He loves it.
He's a,
he's a rise to the occasion Kinda guy.
Tj Is,
and that's one of the reasons why I think he really thrived off this rivalry
with Cody.
Whereas with Cody specially because Tj won the first fight and won it by knock
out,
you know,
Cody like had all this inner tension where TJ had this inner smile like through
the entire process.
Yeah,
definitely.
I definitely agree with you and I think Cody was definitely,
it seemed that he was a little more emotional with the two [inaudible]
and one thing that I,
and what we're talking about,
emotions and fights and everything and one thing that I always remember when
they get emotional,
like even,
and it happens in the sparring sessions and you know,
it might happen in fights and stuff and I always remember Karen and telling me,
you want to be,
that's your phone bro.
How dare you?
How dare you shut that piece of shit.
Now you got Siri going,
you don't even know how to use a phone.
Oh,
I know you're one handed it.
Like as if no one's going to notice.
I am it out of the way.
Volume.
It's still odd.
It's dead.
I killed it.
Go on guest on.
Anyways,
I always remember hours,
remember Kerry and telling me,
because I will get emotional at times and I will let my,
my Peruvian machismo get in the way.
And I was,
you know,
especially like it will happen a lot with Kevin.
You know,
like when Kevin first came to see us,
Kim Ross for Kevin first came to CSA.
Man,
those were all would get beat up a lot.
Call it tough love.
I don't know what you want to call it.
But he was sweet me and beat me up and like,
ah well you want them to give it your best.
And He,
and he made me better heat turned.
He turned me into a training partner versus like somebody,
he had to like my by heat and baby me at any moment.
He,
I built,
he built me into what I am saying we became training partners and,
but one thing they always remember from Karen's,
like you don't want to be emotional.
You want to be like an assassin,
you know,
you want to be,
you want to go in there and be calculator.
You want to be yourself.
Cause that's when I fight the best when I'm myself.
And now when I have no emotion.
Do you have any sort of a pre fight routine that you go through mentally in
order to get yourself into a state of mind?
Like,
you know,
the,
uh,
recently since,
I,
I lost a,
I don't know if you watch my,
my last year's fine,
my second,
uh,
a fiber bells where I guess I got,
I got dropped I guess submitted you got hit with a wheel kit.
We'll,
we'll get gay and see it come out with the triangled how's it going through a
lot of the time of going through a divorce,
you know,
very emotional time of my life last year.
And then I had to,
you know,
dig deep and rise to the occasion and you know,
get out of that hole that I was in.
Um,
so I started grounding my energy before fights.
I was trying to like try to visualize and really see myself,
you know,
doing the things that I would do because that's how I got a lot of my knockouts,
uh,
in lion fight.
I could,
it was the weirdest thing.
I could just visualize and see it.
Like when I knocked out Tyler toner,
I saw that happening before the fight even.
And I was like,
it felt like a Deja Vu moment.
Like,
Oh shit.
Like I've seen this happen and I just like try to like get us calm as I possibly
can.
I just remind myself there's another day in the office and like I've had 50,
almost 50 fights now and I just know that regardless of what happens,
where I win or lose,
I'm like go out there and give it my best.
But what I try to do is to just try to like close my eyes and like,
um,
I call it grinding myself.
I visualize like roots coming out of my feet and hands and I,
I really like ground myself and ground my energy and to visualize roots.
Yeah.
Like tree roads coming out of my hands and coming out on my feet and I like the,
this last fight was crazy actually.
I could visualize it like going all the way into the ring and like once I walked
in there,
I just felt like home.
Oh Wow.
Crazy.
Yeah.
And I don't think I told,
I even told him that just something that you read how to do or is this something
that someone coached you?
Actually,
my ex wife taught me how to do.
Funny enough.
Uh,
she taught me how to do that and I just like,
I thought I was like,
she's fucking bullshitting.
Anyways,
I tried it.
And you tried after you got divorced.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Right.
Yeah.
You've got the roots and he got the kickoffs.
She was right.
I did.
I texted her a while back and I was like,
you were right.
This shit works in this crazy eye.
You know that along with some Alpha brain,
I go out there and I'm like,
I'm ready to rock and roll.
I feel at home
now what,
what I was getting to was that,
that relationship between a coach and athlete when it works out great,
it's so important.
And when you don't have that,
like,
I mean,
there's no disrespect for debt to Danny Castillo and Chris Holdsworth who were
both were very good fighters and I'm sure a dedicated,
but Dwayne is a different kind of thing.
I mean,
he obsesses on various techniques and improvements and foot works and how to
change things and how to,
how to set things up.
He's,
he's all day 24 seven,
he never shuts off.
And the kind of relationship that Dwayne has with Tj is so rare and so
beneficial,
but that the kind of relationship you guys have this kind of really tight
between coach and fighter.
It,
if it's theirs,
you can win without it,
but when you have it,
it is just so powerful.
It's so powerful.
Powerful.
I feel like I like,
it's crazy now,
like when I'm warming up,
like I,
I can see he's getting nervous for me,
but I kind of get,
I,
I see,
I was,
oh shit,
he's worried about me,
you know?
But it makes,
it makes me want to like go in there and like make him proud,
you know?
And like,
I know he's gonna be,
he's gonna be there regardless.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
But like,
I can see,
like,
he,
he tries to hide it as,
oh,
I'm fine.
Like,
you know,
like,
let's get warm,
but I can,
I can just see like that.
Like,
he's getting nervous for me.
You know,
I said,
that just makes me want to do better and go in there and listen to him and just,
well,
you also got to realize how fortunate you are to found him.
I mean,
there's just,
there's not a lot of great Moitai coaches in America where I live out here.
Good luck.
Find a gym to even train at this.
You mean you can go to some guy who's going to hold pads for you,
but like as far as like Legit Moy coaching in the valley,
I mean,
you've got Saxxon,
uh,
or you've got 'em yeah.
On and uh,
Julio out in a van eyes.
Yeah.
But that's,
you know,
it's a half hour,
45 minutes away from here.
Like,
just over this traffic,
man.
Jesus.
Yeah.
That's our 45 minutes at two o'clock in the morning.
Three it'll take you two hours there.
Yeah.
I mean the fact that you just stumbled upon him and this lucky way when you were
that young.
Well,
like I said,
we just clicked,
man.
Yeah.
It just click the,
after I lost that fight against that kid with 80 plus fights.
We just clicked and then I started,
I didn't work my conditioning at all back then.
Like I,
I just ran and training.
I mean,
you have a fucking giant crossfit gym and just know your gym is not just Moy
Tai.
You have a massive fucking gym.
Well,
yeah,
I mean we started out at 5,000 square feet.
Then three years later we went to 12.
Now we're at 25.
Jesus crossfits standalone.
And again,
I have a lot of my people don't use crossfit.
Like Kevin,
he can't keep muscle on.
So he powerlifts with our power lifting coach Jesse Burdick.
He doesn't do crossfit because it's,
it's,
he needs to keep weight on Gaston crossfits.
Um,
and then,
so for us,
everything,
What's unique about our gym is that everything's kind of done under the same
roof.
I don't do a lot of guests coaching.
I'm doing it with the,
with the Alpha male guys because Alex Munoz is coaching wrestling for us.
And I felt for me that was one area that as a gym we needed to grow.
So Alex comes in and coaches,
so I coach his standup and it's been a good beneficial relationship for both
gyms.
Um,
but I don't go there and coach those guys will come down.
Benito works with me now.
Alex works with me.
He'll put Ricardo Ramos who just fought.
Ricardo comes down,
you know,
for the rest of the class we'll have a little sparring session,
like small gloves.
Oh,
we have a full sized cage.
So it's very beneficial.
And then we'll just,
we'll just do like a round Robin type
of thing.
Like one goes in the other ones out and this great like I get really good look
for me.
Those guys.
What made the decision for you to do three different sports?
Like why not dedicate yourself to one?
Okay.
Well I was,
I was,
I started purely as a Meu tie fighter.
Right.
And then the opportunities sound with Belzer came in.
I always,
we always knew that MMA will be,
you know,
where we will end up.
But I just love fighting.
I love fighting.
I love Moyie Thai.
Obviously if I can,
if I could just do more tight,
I'll probably do that.
But,
so if Moitai had the same financial possibilities,
you know,
I used to say that a lot,
actually let me correct myself there.
But now it's like,
I feel,
I feel like I'm getting so much better and like completing my journey as a
martial artist that MMA is definitely where I want to end up at just alone.
And then we had the opportunity with belters to do kickboxing and in the May and
then maybe do a few more.
I fights on the side if,
you know,
it didn't interrupt with anything with,
uh,
with them.
So that's pretty much how it happened.
I mean,
he fought,
he fought five times last year.
Um,
you know,
any fought kickboxing,
MMA and Moyie Thai.
If he was just like with the UFC,
he couldn't do that.
I think Moitai prepares you better for MMA.
Then kickboxing does not just because of the fact you have elbows,
but also because of the fact that the clinic,
the grappling and the people that people don't understand how much grappling
there is tight.
Like when you go to Thailand,
I went to six something on,
uh,
one of the best camps in,
in Bangkok and one of the best camps in the world.
They have said a child was like right now the glory champion,
uh,
one 55.
Uh,
but they clinch twice a day for at least 31 hour,
30 minutes to an hour every day.
That's a lot of grappling,
a lot of grappling and just their ability to rec manipulate each other.
And I think that's one,
that's one thing that has helped me,
has helped my understanding and the wrestling and Jitsu as well.
I pick up things a lot faster than your average Muay Thai fighter.
He probably does just because of that clench.
So,
um,
how much do you do too?
Are you doing,
uh,
what do we focus on right now?
So we have Monday,
about four days a week or four days a week.
Oh,
Jujitsu,
a couple of days of just,
uh,
drills and situational sparring.
So when you're doing a fight,
like your last Beltour fight,
which you just one,
was it two weeks ago?
Three weeks ago?
Three weeks ago,
three weeks ago.
So when,
when you're doing that,
how far out will you just do kickboxing?
Like how much time do you give yourself when you don't do anything else?
Or do you still wrestle and still Jujitsu even though you're
probably still,
I'm fairly new to MMA and to grappling alone,
so I try to just keep a couple of days a week and there so I can,
you know,
keep a fresh,
cause I'm fighting September 29th again,
MMA.
So who are you fighting?
I don't know yet.
We don't have a,
I don't think we have an appointment.
They haven't done it yet.
It's a month away.
Give you an opponent.
It's like six,
like six weeks away.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Not rounds around eight weeks,
something like that.
Yeah,
It's what is today?
The fifth,
6th of August.
Yeah.
Sounds almost take weeks.
Um,
so they give you an opponent and then you have to decide how to prepare.
Like if it's a stand up fighter,
we just ramp up the standup more.
Well most of these guys,
even in the very may,
fighters in their standup guys,
they're getting,
I feel like they're going to try to take me down regardless if they find the
opportunity.
Once it,
once they,
they get cracked,
they're going to want to go on the ground regardless.
So we're always trying to,
you know,
work on getting right back up,
working on keeping control if we're,
if we're in their guards so we don't get submitted with anything.
Like it happened last year in September,
September 23rd.
So we're always what was trying to work all areas regardless.
And I'm always trying to,
as a martial artist,
I always want to be ready for anything that could possibly happen.
You know,
you never,
it's a fight man.
Like anything can happen,
anything can happen,
you know,
and like people always watch tape and fight.
As a fighter,
I've learned that I can involve so much and just six to eight weeks,
you know,
which is like what people have as camps and so you never know who you're going
to get when you're like in front of them,
in the,
in the cage.
So I'm most trying to be ready for anything.
Do you think there's ever going to come a time,
where are you getting to the championship level?
We just stop fighting more and stop fighting kickboxing and just concentrate on
MMA?
Yeah,
probably.
I think,
I think that there's definitely going to be a time that I'm only going to be an
MMA fighter.
I definitely see that in the future.
I'll,
I'll also like to be like one of the first guys to hold a kickbox and bell that,
oh,
I didn't know like Belzer kickboxing world championship.
Uh,
and be like a top contender.
I want to be definitely that,
that kind of guy that can do,
they can prove that they can do both.
You know,
at a hide a super high level.
It's a,
it's interesting.
Bell tour is really starting to make progress.
I mean they,
they have real legit world class fighters now.
You know,
they have gay garden.
We saw sees arguably if not the best,
one of the best 185 pounders in the world.
I mean,
in my opinion,
he's right up there with Robert Whitaker and he's willing to,
the marrow is,
his striking is he's a beast.
Jeez.
I'm a big fan of massage.
Yeah,
I am too.
But he's super well rounded too.
I mean with everything and it just so calm.
His demeanor,
his mentality.
He's,
he's,
he's an assassin like legitimate acid as his Roy MacDonald and they're both,
yeah,
that's the car that I'm fighting on.
I'm super excited.
Come on.
That made you decide to make like why the fuck would you do that?
Like I don't understand why you would take,
arguably you're your best two guys
fight and they're not even in the same weight class.
I mean,
I guess to me,
I super fight.
There's pressure with the super fight movement with the UFC for Bella Torta to
keep up.
I know.
I think there's,
there's,
there's probably,
and again,
it might not be Scott's idea.
Might be Paramount's idea.
Don't know.
Well it could very well be Rory and k Garth's idea too.
I mean they might call each other out right away as a massage.
He became the champion of one in five.
They were like,
listen man,
fucking psycho.
I mean he's a legit fucking psycho in the best way possible.
It was really good.
God,
you get to know him at all.
Not at all.
Wait,
we're both on the on,
on,
uh,
the monster team with Hans and all those guys.
Oh,
shout out to hands on.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Try and try and be knighted.
Yeah,
I got it.
He just sent me a bunch of gloves and shit.
And you guys were saying that bags of the best backs.
Yeah,
definitely.
Absolutely.
His gloves,
the death adder,
they go,
I don't know if you,
I think,
I think as I have a pair,
it's my favorite glove.
He makes great gloves.
Favorite glove.
Oh,
knows his shit.
Yeah,
definitely.
Um,
so what we're just saying,
we were talking about Rory.
Oh,
what I was saying is like,
people had this idea of who he was and then he came on and did my podcast.
And people are like,
oh,
he's fucking normal.
He's a good guy.
Like everybody thought he was like this autistic.
So I go,
yeah,
he never Muni came with you but just wouldn't never met people.
From what I heard from Hans,
he's like a super nice guy.
Very smart,
very intelligent.
He's funny actually.
You know,
it's just his fight with Lawler was like one of my favorite fight.
The fulltime Jesus Christ.
What a crazy fight.
First Time I ever saw him was when he fought Nate.
I was there with,
when Jake fought GSP cornering.
Jake has candida,
right?
It was in Canada,
in Toronto.
And uh,
I didn't know who he was and,
and I watched that fight for the back and I was just like,
Holy Shit,
this kid is phenomenal.
And I don't think anybody anticipated his level of wrestling at that time.
I think may thought he was going to be up to slap them up.
And,
uh,
you know,
that after that I became a huge,
huge fan.
I mean,
obviously Nate's my boy and I love Nate and you know,
to wrong weight class.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
one thing to fight Conor at one 70,
but Rory,
he's giant one 70,
and he's also training with GSP and just Tristar and I'm a giant fan of for Rasa
hobby and what he's managed to put together up there in Montreal,
they just have a camp that's just,
it's just such an elite camp,
you know,
it's just a different,
different level of,
uh,
of,
just well rounded fighters.
It's a fucking phenomenal place.
Foot,
phenomenal,
phenomenal coach.
One of my favorites,
one of my favorite coaches.
I'm excited to see Nate fight pour you and I'm excited to see neat back.
You know,
I was,
I was wondering,
I was like,
fuck man,
it's been like two years.
Yeah,
I was surprised he took the fight and then I was also surprised that he was mad
that they were doing,
uh,
controversies.
Khabib.
I didn't expect that at all.
They're both Matt Dustin's mad too.
I was like,
what the fuck are you guys mad for?
Well,
I thought Dustin was going to wait for,
you know,
to get his title shot,
but I guess that fight makes sense man.
He might not have got that title shot though.
Tony Ferguson's healing up,
you know,
he's back in the mix.
Who knows what's going to happen with a James Vick when James Vick is gonna
fight 'em uh,
Justin Gagey Vicks on I think at 10 or 11 fight win streak.
That was something crazy like that Kras pounds
stacked.
That's a stacked weight class man.
You know,
and then you still have so many guys that are,
that are coming up that are,
you know,
like one or two fights away.
Then of course you got fucking Kevin Lee who in my opinion has the best argument
for the next title shot.
He's a monster monster.
His last fight.
So it's him.
Tony Ferguson.
When Tony's healthy again,
Tony's not 100% healthy,
but I mean,
Dustin,
I think it's right to take that fight because he's not the most compelling guy.
I know he wants to,
but he just got knocked out by Michael Johnson a year ago.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's a lot,
maybe a little bit more than a year ago,
but it's like still and then you got to remember what Johnson when when Johnson
fought Khabib,
Khabib,
Malden.
I mean there's a lot of,
a lot of people in that weight class.
So Johnson went down to 45 though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Johnson's Johnson's fight in Philly.
Yeah.
Philly's coming down to a training with us as well as his first fight at 45 to
Darren Elkins and a,
and he looked really good physically look,
he was ripped for the first time and he was shredded.
But I wonder like,
man,
how much does he walk around that he's a big fellow.
Like how much do you walk around that and how much does he depleting his body to
get down to that 100 that's one thing.
Like I don't think like some people like realize like,
yeah,
okay,
you made the way.
You only come in like seven,
eight pounds like the night before,
but we're depleting your body throughout like that camp.
Yeah,
I think I can definitely,
you know,
people ask me like,
Hey,
are you going to go to Bantam?
And I'm like,
fuck no man.
I like,
I like feeling good throughout.
You walk around at like one 62 oh that's not too bad.
Not Too.
And that's what people tell me in pounds.
That's what people tell him.
He said,
Oh,
you could probably make Bantam weight.
And I was like,
yeah man.
But like I like to feel strong physically,
mentally strong throughout my camp thing only cut like eight to 10 pounds.
We don't,
we don't cut a lot of weight at CSA.
I don't smart,
I don't,
I don't like it.
I don't want it.
And I,
and part of it is,
you know,
I got this kid knocked out.
I'm telling you right now.
I got,
it was my,
as a coach,
you have to own it.
It was my fault.
Fight Week.
I'm going to take five extra pounds off of this kid,
you know,
just because he's not going to fight.
Okay.
Then we don't fight.
You learn as you go.
Um,
so no,
I have a 10% rule.
I'll pull you like what one FC is doing.
You know,
we had been asked her in here and he was explaining how one at one fc does these
hydration tests.
They test you all the time.
They tests you several times.
They find out what your actual weight is.
They test your hug [inaudible] levels.
Yeah.
Several times they moved everybody up to weight class.
They kept their champions,
but they made,
you know Ben,
instead of a one and 70,
they made him a one 85 pound champ.
California's doing hydration tests on fight day,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Which I just fight day.
There were also,
I don't think it works that well.
No.
Well,
they're also making you not weigh more than 10% more than what you weighed in
and moved up a couple that they don't,
I don't think they find you.
You're,
you're the first time you do it.
They just like advice you to go up and they don't like,
I think that on that allow you to fight at that same weight.
If he's for a 200 pound fighter,
that's 20 fucking pounds.
That's a lot of weight,
man.
That's a lot of weight.
Like if I pulled 20 pounds of water out of my body right now,
I mean I'd be stumbling in walls.
I mean you're on death's door.
I mean you're not early.
You're not going to take shots the same way.
You're just not fucking way and your Oregon's here's,
that's a big thing.
Your Oregon start fucking up.
I know a guy who,
well I know someone who knows him.
He was a in a bodybuilding competition and this is a 36 year old guy who's,
you know,
just amateur bodybuilding competition,
got down to a really low body fat and just really wanting to win the
competition.
One and then two weeks afterwards his fucking body shutdown is Oregon started
shutting down.
He had a heart attack.
It's family found him dead.
Just Dido.
Hardtack 36 years old now the water comes out of the organs.
Last and it goes back in last.
What's also the damage due to them.
Why?
By depleting them and trying them out.
Your kidneys.
Going back to that,
that fight that I got knocked out,
I cut all that weight I made the way,
you know I was,
I weighed in every but I couldn't keep water in.
I just like,
I was drinking and like I just felt like shit I could,
I couldn't like I went to bed probably like only a couple of pounds heavier
after cutting like 12 pounds.
Yeah.
Like I was just,
I couldn't keep water in like I was taking pedialyte and stuff like that as
well.
And he works at dolce now.
However I do it the smart way,
but back then like we'll just do whatever,
iterate in anything.
Like I just couldn't,
I didn't even eat that night because I couldn't hold anything in.
My stomach just went in such at like stage that I was just like,
love you compared methods.
Like if you guys talked to Lockhart and different cars and see how everybody
does it.
Does everybody do it the same way?
No.
Not Everybody's doing it the same way Mo.
Most people are using a probiotic,
right?
Probiotics rehydrate,
no two to get your stomach ready to start digesting food again and,
and all of that.
So what probiotic do they use?
It depends on who's sponsoring them,
you know?
Um,
so for us right now,
you know,
we're using Mike stuff.
Mike's been tremendous to the team through the years.
It's all natural.
I mean,
you know,
his rehydration drink is water,
Himalayan salt,
honey,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
I'm not going to put it out there,
but it's all natural stuff and it's all stuff that you're taking during,
you know,
you're like,
I'm always having Chia seeds and they million salt and honey.
I like Lockhart,
but literally,
I know that,
you know,
he worked with Dustin and there were three different shaped bottles that Dustin
had to consume,
which Dustin Ortiz before his last fight,
the head kick,
you got to let everybody know there's million people,
million Dentons yes,
that's an Ortiz Ortiz.
Uh,
and he had three different shaped bottles and each one had different ingredients
to be taken at different times.
And it was just really hard for Dustin and keep track of all that.
Is there science behind that though?
That I don't know.
I don't know enough about what,
what Georgia's doing.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I get that it would be hard to keep track of it,
but if there's a tangible benefit to keeping track of those three different
things.
Yeah.
For me,
the natural method that dolce uses is what I'll use if,
if a fighter is not paying hydration drink and you make so much of it,
like a gallon or whatever and you're only absorbing chia seeds.
Pink Himalayan salt,
Lemon Pink Himalayan salt.
When it said it sounded like you said Pinky mill and so no thank Himalayan salt
instead it again,
you should hear a basketballer you sheer mass for PAC worked.
I have.
Can we do [inaudible] at your Spanish?
I've only been speaking English for what,
like 12 years.
Come on man.
No big deal.
Coach,
can we do packet work tonight?
Sure.
So I'm sorry.
Uh,
Chia seeds.
Pink Himalayan salt.
Lemon.
Honey.
Why honey?
What does the honey for?
I don't know the pros buying.
I just put it tastes good.
It definitely tastes good.
Yeah.
You're going to take some of the sting off of the salt and uh,
just for a little bit of the,
the,
the carb and the sugar.
So right off the scale,
you take 16 ounces of the drink with some fruit and then you wait 50 minutes.
So you're absorbing all the nutrients versus like drinking or eating too much,
which is why,
oh,
it used to probably one,
which right away,
which is probably what happened.
That was,
I was uh,
I was a fucking mad scientist at that time.
I'm like,
Oh okay we're going to take a little bit in this creatine and nice because you
know,
every ounce of carbs,
you know,
you're going to hold three ounces of water and create teams going to make
[inaudible] as creating help.
You rehydrate.
Cause it does make you retain water.
Right.
But if you're not taking creatine,
normally you know it,
it's going to be.
But again,
at the time,
early on in my career,
you know,
a lot of everything that I've done from hand wrapping to conditioning to a
hydration,
it,
it's all learn as you go.
Creating does make you stronger.
It really does work,
but it also makes you face fat.
Definitely makes you,
if you just put more mass about it,
winter coat on creatine monohydrate.
And as far as like Cree,
alkaline and all these are the creatine monohydrate is one of the only proven
supplements legally that can make you stronger then.
But again,
whether or not it's good for you,
you know,
science says whatever.
But at the time I think it is good for you.
That's actually,
I believe it is.
And it's actually been proven to actually have a Jamie Google a creatine
nootropic benefits because I feel like I remember reading that they're,
um,
they're actually finding that there's some cognitive benefit to taking creatine
team.
No,
actually
I read this and read the same thing and more water.
Absolutely.
Your brain would function better because you know how it is when you're
dehydrated.
You can't fucking remember shit,
my brain's useless when I'm dehydrated.
We'll think about cutting 12 pounds of ice to do it here.
The old taekwondo days and fight the same day and no heat,
no re hydration,
didn't know what I was doing.
And when I went from one 40 to one 54 that's when I got good.
When I,
when I stopped cutting all the weight before that I was just a Zombie.
It's,
I see it in these guys.
I see these guys show up at the,
the way in and I see their sunken eyes.
They're sunk in cheek and it,
it makes me sick man.
Which is why I constantly harp on this fucking one FC thing,
you know?
And I talked to the UFC guys,
I talked to him a couple times.
So it was like,
look,
you guys have implemented this unbelievable innovative and,
and,
and really just fantastic strategy for cutting out all the steroid use.
I mean,
what you guys done is amazing.
It's so progressive.
You're on top of it.
You're ahead of everybody and you're really setting the standard to that shit
with weight cutting.
They should do that shit with weight cutting Ti.
Don't,
don't blow up your champions.
Move them,
move them.
Move them to just decide.
You have real champions.
Eight reasons.
Creatines the best nootropic there it is.
Creatine is a molecule.
Allow cells to store energy in your brain cells for use at another time.
This extra energy means you could do more work or study more effectively.
Unlike caffeine,
you don't feel like you have more energy.
I'll,
this is not a science journal.
What is this?
Like someone's blog or some shit,
but negates symptoms of sleep deprivation.
Oh Shit.
I need some of that sometimes too.
I just got back from Thailand.
I was in Thailand for nine days and I've been back for a week and I still wake
up after sleeping for two hours and I'm like,
what the fuck?
Why am I awake?
And then I go downstairs,
I'll eat,
I'll watch TV.
And I'm like,
I'll just,
might as well just work out.
I'm wide awake.
And then an hour later exhausted.
Can't,
can't wait to go to sleep,
go to sleep for more hours.
The train at all out of there.
No,
I have a meniscus tear.
I was just there with my family for a vacation.
But I would say very fascinating thing that happened to me.
I had a meniscus tear,
small meniscus tear and a,
I went running on it.
I was doing yoga on it and it was seemed to be fine.
Then I ran on it because it seemed like it was just kind of like,
like my knee was just a little sore and then after I ran on it,
it locked up on me like it was really tight.
So I said,
fuck,
I got to go get an MRI.
So I get an MRI.
They say,
yeah,
you've got a meniscus tear.
Um,
you can get him in this copy.
Is that what they say at Mississippi?
Whatever,
whatever,
when the operation or we could try exosomes exosomes,
which is a,
it's an ass Google exosomes.
So we can explain it in a technical way.
But I,
I had some of that shot into my shoulder with miraculous results.
I mean I've had a bunch of different things done to my shoulder and then I
always wind up reinjuring it partially.
And then I'll get more stem cells.
This had by far the greatest benefit of anything I've ever done.
Well.
So I get it shot into my knee.
When I say within two weeks I had no pain.
I mean fucking nothing like deep squats.
No problem.
Not Bothering me at all.
And I was doing no only bodyweight stuff for like six weeks.
I need it.
I need to know about it.
I'm telling you from my wife,
she was my test dummy file.
Incredible with this has done,
I ran yesterday,
ran in the hills for the first time in six weeks.
Zero pain,
zero discomfort.
I was,
I woke up this morning say fuck,
you better not be stiff.
I don't feel it man.
It feels like there's nothing there that's impressive.
Regenerative medicine.
What they're doing with Tj Dillashaw had done,
Tj Dillashaw went down to Panama on two separate occasions to uh,
work with Doctor Neil Riordan.
Who is doing that in Panama.
Well,
they're also doing similar things right now.
They're able to do that in Santa Monica,
but under some sort of a test thing.
They're doing like test study to see how their stuff works.
But it,
they do it with PRP as well.
So they,
they put exosomes in your body and they inject it with PRP and the PRP and the
exosomes work together and regenerate tissue.
It's radical shit man.
I mean it's used to have a meniscus tear.
Your knee was fucked up for months and it was,
if it was so stiff that you couldn't walk without a limp is not going to get
better in a week.
This shit was better in a week and two weeks there was zero,
zero even recognition that there was anything wrong.
It didn't feel like there was anything wrong.
Well that is crazy.
It's fucking nuts man.
And this is,
you know,
here we are in 2018 2028 they're going to grow you a new fucking leg
really close to some crazy shit.
Do you know they're repairing completely torn ACL is now instead of replacing
them your ACL snaps,
they've figured out a way to repair them where they got someone back to the u s
bobsled team four months after the operation.
That's crazy.
Fucking crazy.
They've got guys doing box jumps for months after complete ACL tear.
My wife competed at the crossfit games four months after ACL replacement.
How'd she do that?
Doctor Mauri Harwood and uh,
uh,
lowest closeup possible.
But the,
the ACO would not have been reformed by the APP.
No,
she had no,
she had it replaced.
Right.
But the cadaver graft to understand it's just a scaffolding.
Understood.
So it wouldn't have been fully formed by then.
Well,
the way we'll see,
here's the thing,
it's the way,
the way crossfit works.
This is not an impact.
It's not a contact sport.
Right.
So surgery in October,
she was competing again in February,
rights in November,
December,
January,
February.
And then by the time the games rolled around in July,
she was now at like that eight month mark.
So that was yours.
Okay.
They say six months is when it's really pretty much healed.
But she was in the gym the next day.
Right.
It's like literally you have ACL
surgery.
Well,
I fall.
Your Wife,
Jessica.
Jessica is married to a maniac.
I made,
I made her a maniac when I met her.
She was at when,
I bet she did.
A lot of it are so when I know when I met her,
she was a hippie and she was an actress.
Seriously.
That the level of maniac that she has.
They nobody making that.
No,
no,
that's true.
It's definitely let us know.
But yeah,
there's a fucking room that's always been there filled with crazy.
Oh No,
she's,
she's uh,
she's amazing.
43 she doing her first figure competition now she took the year off of figure.
What does that it goes bodybuilding type of deal.
Yeah.
She's never done it.
So she,
she set like a bunch of powerlifting records.
She went to the Games twice.
She fought,
she was on the US hockey team.
Um,
and now she's going to a finger comp and then,
you know,
she's,
she's crazy.
She's mom.
Wow.
His mom.
It's your mom.
And I don't know if you saw that picture that I posted from my last kickbox and
fight it,
but it was uh,
it was carrying in the corner and it was Jessica right there holding the eyes.
I was like an amazing mason pictures.
It's amazing that she could start training that hard four months later because a
lot of people will,
especially the real issue with fighters is the lateral movement.
Yeah.
It's all the footwork and the movement and that's when they always wind up
blowing their knee out.
Like so many guys.
I told my mcls here completely two weeks before is I'm a Davis.
She is,
yeah,
Yup.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But she,
so like,
but most people,
like you said,
she's a maniac.
Most people aren't like her when they give you that range of motion machine,
the day after surgery,
they say you should be in this five hours a day.
She's in it five hours a day every day.
And she was in the gym the next day rowing with her legs straight.
I mean there's just a,
there's a level of just dedication and commitment to rehab at that she had,
when I tore my ACL,
I have a steam room in my house and uh,
I would just get in there every day in too deep squats and the steam room and
just through the pain.
But because of that,
I never had an issue with any range of motion whatsoever where I've had two
friends that have had ACL operations was in the past year that had to go back
and go under and get manipulated because they didn't have range emotion.
Wow.
So they,
they take you,
put you out and just take your name like crap because you just can't handle the
pain.
Right.
That's all it is.
But in my opinion,
take that pain early so that body,
it never has a chance to lock up and,
and all that scar tissue developed.
Just break that shit down real early.
Yeah.
Well I was,
like I said,
I tore my MCL completed,
gone off the top of the bone last year,
five weeks before my MMA fight.
MMA debut,
five weeks,
tore it off the bone.
Yeah,
it was like I go in and the doctor's like,
listen man,
I don't want to scare you,
but it's probably the worst MCL injury I've ever seen.
Oh,
you don't want to scare me.
Shout out to Dr Donnelly.
Uh,
but it's
gone.
It's going to hurt.
But you know it's gone.
So what does it gain?
It's gone.
[inaudible] is gone.
That you can start,
you can start training.
The can start.
He's like,
this is the way he explains like listen,
like I,
you might not be able to find him five weeks out on,
no,
I'm not sure.
You don't,
I wouldn't recommend surgery because you're an athlete.
You would recommend surgery because you're an athlete.
That's what he said.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
He's like,
you should,
you should start doing PT.
Uh,
normally I don't recommend this to like until two weeks after the injury,
but he didn't explain why he wouldn't recommend surgery because you're an
athlete and they will put me out for six months,
but it will heal it 100%.
Is that the idea is you're an active addict?
No.
What?
He's leaving out as he had so much stability already.
Did the ice.
He said it was like he's a 48 hours later.
It looks pretty good considering Utah completely off the boat he was,
other than the MRI,
you wouldn't know that the MCL was gone.
Okay.
So now when it's torn off the bone,
explain what happens.
Can you,
so it was on top of the bone.
So the MCL is,
um,
the outside or is it the Ltl?
Inside.
And so it's on the inside and it's separated from the bone.
So how's it heal?
How To heal?
It was,
he said,
well he's,
well,
he said is because it's on top of the bone that you have merchants and much
less.
Yeah.
So there's the MCL.
So at tour off the bone,
right on the top,
he said,
Huh.
So ripped off completely.
Yeah.
The whole thing.
Grappling.
Yeah.
Gone.
So the whole thing's gone.
Yeah.
So it was no MCL?
Nope.
So you don't have an MCL right now?
No,
I don't know.
I,
I'm fine now.
He just don't know.
He doesn't have it.
Mcl.
Right.
So,
but all the other stuff and the muscles keep it intact.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So what he said is,
man,
but did you think that like for long term stability,
the long for your longterm career probably be a good idea to have an MCL?
I'm not,
I haven't had a problem with him and I fought three different comments for us.
It hasn't bothered me.
If I was,
I was running,
doing full sprints two and a half weeks later after it happened.
Wow.
Which was,
he was like,
he saw me walk in and say,
where's your base man?
I was like,
oh,
it's in the car.
I don't need it anymore.
It hurts.
It kind of pinches,
pinches the knee.
He's like,
what do you mean?
I was like,
oh,
I just got cleared to run.
So he,
he told me I ran it to happen.
It's like,
listen,
like I told them the situation,
I was like,
I have a fight.
I have a fight in five weeks.
I need to get ready for it.
It's my debut is a big thing.
It's in my,
it's my MMA debut was a big thing.
It's like,
I dunno man,
like it's Kinda your call on this one that you might be able to fight.
You might like see how you feel type of thing.
I'll,
I'll allow you to do PT starting tomorrow.
So what I did,
I was doing PT and that was doing cryotherapy twice a day,
every day.
So I was keeping the swine down and trying to strengthen the leg at the same
time.
But you that MCL,
it's not a partial tear.
It's a full tail gone.
He told him,
he's like,
there's nothing you can do about it.
It's gone.
It's going to hurt to hear it.
This right here.
Yeah.
So it's a grade three tear.
Gone.
So you don't have that thing.
Yeah.
And they probably can't even replace it at this point unless there's some sort
of a cadaver one and then you'd be out for six months.
Yeah.
And he fought five times since you fuck everything about that Bro.
He was like,
he did to this days.
I you,
you changed my perception and mcls completely cause he hasn't,
he didn't believe it when I tell him I can run now.
Does he ever work with athletes?
I told him,
he told me he used to be that his doctor.
That's all he does.
He focuses on how does he,
that seems so crazy.
Maybe of an unusual knee.
I don't know.
I just,
I just ate a lot of Maca powder.
Peruvian mind is that Maca powder and that cup of calm about it and that was it.
That that is insane.
You know,
you don't need that.
I committed.
I committed a law to my,
to my rehab though.
I was,
like I said,
I was doing twice a day doing cryotherapy,
ice and they're trying to do everything I possibly could to fight.
I'll,
I'll also say that,
you know,
you get a lot of bad raps,
with crossfit and listen,
it doesn't matter what it is.
It could be spin,
it could be crossfit,
it can be taekwondo,
it does it.
There's good crossfit,
there's bad crossfit,
there's good taekwondo,
there's bad taekwondo.
At the end of the day,
this kid had been doing,
uh,
you know,
physical,
general,
physical preparedness for years.
He's in phenomenal shape.
Everything that he does,
uh,
you know,
the stability in his legs.
Like I gave him a,
I gave him a stability test after he hurt his knee and I couldn't,
I'm like,
I think it's still there.
I said,
go get an MRI,
be sure.
But there was no movement in his leg whatsoever because he's so strong.
That's pretty crazy and pretty fortunate.
Right?
Yeah.
And I was lucky.
It was definitely like he still doesn't believe it to this day that it happened.
So what else do you do in terms of like a recuperative,
you said you did cryotherapy.
Do you do sauna work at all?
I liked the infrared sauna.
Yeah.
But that,
I just started doing that recently.
I was just doing a lot of the cryotherapy.
I don't know if there's any benefit to infrared.
Is there,
do you know your body needs to heat up?
That's all it is.
Is there a benefit to using infrared as opposed to a regular sauna?
Eh,
again,
I mean there are 10,000 people that were probably screaming that we gave Korea
Tina a shot out.
And I'm sure there are people that are going to say infrared is benefit and
infrared kills you.
Um,
but I do believe that,
you know,
again,
hot,
cold therapy works and you're getting your body hot and you know,
getting your body cool and,
and manipulating your metabolism a is something that uh,
needs to be done and should be done.
Yeah,
well it's heat shock proteins and cold shock proteins that reduce inflammation.
And there's a lot of studies on that board in the more interesting studies is on
sauna use and the fact that this reduction of inflammation has led to a 40%
reduction in overall cause.
Mortality Meaning in awe on all cause mortality.
Mortality Means Strokes,
heart attacks,
cancer,
40% reduction over long,
long study that they did and I think were doing it four times
a week for 20 minutes a day.
What's fucking crazy?
But if that reduction of inflammation,
inflammation is the number one enemy,
it's the enemy of your health.
It's the cause of so many diseases.
And ailments and,
and if you can do something to mitigate that,
whether it's a cryotherapy or sauna work,
and then cryotherapy gets a bad rap too.
Cause there's a lot of unfounded claims,
you know,
you,
you'd go to some of those more unscrupulous cryotherapy websites and you know,
they're basically making shit up.
They bash it.
Well,
I mean the ones that are talking good about it,
the ones that are selling it,
they're talking about how much fat you lose and all this different stuff.
Like,
look,
it reduces inflammation.
It's what it does.
It's really good for that.
You know,
good afternoon.
Yeah.
Well if you're training on a regular basis,
you're an athlete,
that inflammation can be detrimental.
And that's just all it is.
The more that you can do and do it in all these different ways with diet and
exercise and sleep and all these different,
you're,
you're it all they all compound
for,
for me,
my,
my philosophy with the Jim has always been,
and again,
it's very basic and of course there's something like,
you know,
overtraining,
but you know,
no such thing as overtraining.
Just talking to recovery.
Know.
So we trained really hard.
Everybody's doing two,
three a days.
We do a lot of road work.
We do a lot of strength conditioning.
Um,
you know,
we don't get tired in fights,
but,
you know,
sleeping is important.
Uh,
you know,
recovery,
inflammation management,
uh,
you know,
everything along those lines has to be part of it.
Or you're gonna break your body down to a point where you can't perform to
fighters ever give you a hard time for being a little overweight.
No,
no,
nope.
Never,
never cast on you missing out.
Let me,
let me let,
well,
I don't want to,
I don't want to know pat word.
You hear that?
Um,
so no.
You know,
this is a guy who understands health,
wellness a hundred,
a hundred percent.
I'm the,
I'm the crossfit affiliate holder and I don't do crossfit.
I,
I'm a human heavy bag.
It's what I do is literally what I do.
I run a gym.
I get beat up for a living hope pass.
You know,
there's,
there's nobody that holds pat.
Like,
literally my day can be Kevin Ross gassed on Gina Carano Zoya for Asto Eddie
episode low Diego.
Yamice a little Stephanie who fucking,
it's harder at or as hard as Jenna,
my giant Kiwi,
uh,
you know,
and that's four hours of my life.
Every night my body's adapted to that.
I'll sweat like a pig.
I won't drop a pound.
Um,
I don't eat that much.
I probably don't eat enough.
I just,
I live my gym,
so absolutely I'm going to die of a heart attack or I'm going to get my shit
together.
Um,
you know,
I don't think I'm morbidly obese,
but I certainly don't look like a guy who knows about fitness,
but I do.
It's just you have to put yourself first.
And it's very difficult for me as a coach to put myself first.
I have to,
if there's time for me to work out,
there's time for me to get somebody else a fight.
If there's time for me not to be a diet thing,
there's no way he'll tell you,
well,
what do you eat in the morning?
I'll have a shake,
uh,
in the afternoon.
I'll have a meal and then I'll eat that meal though.
So no,
no,
no.
Like A,
like a prepaid meal,
like a,
an out of the cave meal,
his food sponsor.
It's,
it's,
it's a matter of probably not eating enough,
uh,
and not working out,
doing something that my body's not used to it.
I would be honest,
I would,
I live,
trust me,
I live with a physical specimen,
you know,
that knows everything I eat.
I don't,
I don't eat enough and I treat sense.
I'm telling you I,
that doesn't make any sense.
That'd be like,
look,
scientifically,
it doesn't make any sense.
I guarantee you I take in less than 2,500 calories a day.
Guarantee you,
you should go to the doctor.
I would need time for,
they'll have the time to go.
Doctor.
I live in my gym.
I don't,
and again,
it sounds like excuses,
but literally you could be a thyroid issue or something.
Could be me.
It seems like that's on TV because you're making it sound like I'm living a 600
pound life and it's not exactly the same.
I mean,
we're talking about health and wellness and you know,
this is the elephant in the room.
Not,
aw,
I saw dick
that's just saying no.
I mean,
because you are such a,
uh,
a talented coach and you know so much about health and fitness that,
you know,
that's theirs.
That's a thing.
Yeah,
absolutely.
100%,
100% for fighting.
I think it's Kevin.
Kevin will give me grief,
you know,
but he's really the only one that gets away with it.
Well,
Kevin's a Hummingbird,
right?
He can't keep weight on.
No,
exactly.
Exactly.
But no for so,
so for me it's just,
it's a matter of just making time and I just,
I don't make time for myself.
I just don't,
well,
that's probably why you're such a good coach to the obsession that a coach has.
It's,
it's such a different obsession.
The obsession that a coach has versus the obsession that a fighter has.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a completely different focus.
It's an outward focus instead of in,
in my,
in my model is,
is totally different.
I don't think we've ever talked about it.
I've never taken a dime from a professional fighter ever.
You don't get paid at all?
Nope.
How do you make,
so you make a living off the crossfit for the gym?
Not just the crossfit.
I have membership,
gym memberships.
That's it.
I've never in my entire life,
Alexis fought Ronda.
This kid's got 50 fights.
Kevin run down the list.
I've never taken a penny from a professional.
You have to be completely unique in that.
I mean,
I don't think there's anybody else.
I,
I don't,
I don't ever heard of that before.
No.
If it would be like for me it would be like if the Golden State Warriors paid
the coach directly,
uh,
who's,
who's running,
who's running the asylum,
then that's an interesting way to look at it.
I don't work for him.
I worked with him.
Right pad work,
travel,
like I won't even take per diem on fight week of the UFC.
I mean,
I'm going to take Lexuses fights twice a year.
She's got a kid and I'm going to take her per diem money.
Right.
It can't.
No.
I can't.
As a coach that really when I advise him,
this is a good fight for you,
this is a bad fight for you.
This,
it can't be motivated by me making money.
It just,
it for me.
I can't do that.
Well,
I know you put together this,
uh,
you,
you are,
you're really well known as not just being a coach,
but as training other coaches that,
that coaching seminar that you do,
you do it every year,
twice a year,
twice a year.
It is one of the most respected and appreciated seminar series and all of combat
sports because it's one of the things that's missing.
How do you run a gym correctly?
Absolutely.
The fact that you're willing to open up the door to all these other coaches and
potential competitors,
right?
And,
and let them do that.
It just speaks volumes about your approach and anybody,
anybody can come.
And so when I opened up and I started,
I didn't know what I was doing.
You know,
I was a fighter when I was younger.
Uh,
and then I had to get a real job when my wife got pregnant and I got into a
bunch of other stuff.
They didn't tell your protection and all that crazy stuff.
What protection?
Dignitary protection.
What does that,
um,
executive security consulting.
Oh,
so you're doing like bodyguard work for yeah,
I'm boil it.
Terry's,
yeah.
Dignitaries.
So it's a weird word,
right?
No,
it's the actual word to hear Terry dignitary protection or you're working with
like foreign agents and stuff like that?
Yeah,
it was on the presidential protection detail for airspeed in Haiti.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
How weird is that?
Yeah,
I've had,
I've had a couple of jobs.
If you Google me,
you go like five pages back,
you'll hear all that other stuff.
But I so cause the fighting wasn't paying when I was fighting my,
my wife got pregnant and my son's 21,
I think I made 500 bucks the most.
Everyone I fought and you know,
I had to get a real job.
So I was going to school and uh,
and I was going to be a cop and then I met a guy,
Tony.
Scotty,
the Godfather of defensive tactics driving.
He let me in on a course with the State Department.
I impressed him and he made some introductions and I became a State Department
subcontractor and traveled the world and you know,
ran a company,
one of the largest private security companies in the world.
Steel Foundation.
I think.
They don't think they're around anymore.
I retired.
That's so interesting because whenever I see a gym as big as yours and I know
how hard it is to run a gym,
I always go,
ha,
how did that happen?
How'd that,
how'd that come together like that?
Because you know,
it's just so many gyms.
Common go and even good ones like look with MMA gyms.
We lost the Blackzilians.
That's gone.
I don't know what's going on with a team elevate in Denver.
I think that's where it Tj was.
Yes,
he did his camp here.
Yeah,
there.
Now.
Now they're at the,
what do they call it?
The training?
Yeah.
Rain.
Ari.
Supposing lab doesn't have anything to do with the old rain.
No,
no,
no.
Mark is,
where's
mark?
Mark.
Mark Andrews is somewhere else.
Now,
here's how so,
so I've got just about,
been open for nine years with CSA.
We had zero members when we started.
I've got about 1300 what was the motivation?
The motivation was that I spent,
it was always a passion.
I was doing martial arts when I was a child.
I was fighting,
I just wasn't making money doing it.
And then I got into that other life and did that for about 15 years and I was
being paid to protect people that could afford it,
but maybe didn't deserve it for a very long time.
And unfortunately that's the way it works is if you can afford it,
you probably don't deserve it.
That's a funny way of life.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a true way of looking at it because I was doing it at the highest level.
You know,
I wasn't doing security work at the kids' choice awards,
standing,
you know,
to Jim Carey for two hours saying I'm Jim Carey's bodyguard.
Right?
So it's one of those things where I saw it at the very highest level and it
just,
it turned me off after a while because you know,
you're just,
you're,
you're being a babysitter to people who have money.
Right.
Even with the biggest threats,
you know,
from Iraq,
Afghanistan,
a Haiti run down the list.
It wasn't about helping people and always wanting to help people.
So when I,
when I opened the gym,
that was the goal was to help people and it,
it turned into that gym.
And this is why I feel that our gym model is successful is because tonight at
five 30 during a boxing class,
my professional fighters are going to be in class with everyone else.
There's no protein only practice.
Everybody trains together.
Everybody works together.
The model is for people.
You want to get in shape,
wonderful.
You're going to get in the shape.
You want to have stress relief.
Wonderful.
You want to become a fighter.
I don't have a fight team practice try out or any of that.
You come to the gym and you put in the work,
you support the team,
you trained side by side with world champions,
you get better,
you have a good time.
It's a huge family,
Jim.
a environment and the mixture of the self defense and the fighting and the
fitness one doesn't need the other.
So unlike like an Aka,
and I love Javie,
but the gym is about the fighters in a fighter's lose.
People go out the back door for me,
I kind of a fight or lose,
my membership's not going to matter by,
people are still going to come,
there's still going to train,
they're still gonna support.
They're still going to buy tickets.
And that's been the recipe.
And because of the gym is that way,
it's allowed me to have this model where I don't charge pro fighters.
So when you opened that,
that is really incredible and very,
very unique.
But when you open,
like how'd you get people to go?
Well when,
so what I would say,
I'm going to,
I'm going to sound full of myself here.
I'm just,
I'm very good at it.
Sure.
And you open up a gym,
it was going to go,
hey,
I want to go train with Mr. Perfect.
That's Ernesto,
who's,
you know,
for a guy like you to have such a massive,
massive gym and become one of the most respected gyms in the world.
Right?
Like it's,
it's a crazy path.
Like W so for me,
I think part of it was just,
I'm going to use a generic term hustle.
You know,
I,
you know,
like you look at Thai boxing coaches,
like you said,
there just aren't very good.
Did the ties here in America,
they don't take it seriously.
It's not the stadium.
If you're not in the stadium,
they don't care.
So you know,
other than John [inaudible] name a Thai coach that's coaching high level
fighters,
Thai boxing,
they're just not,
it's,
they're retired.
It's boring.
It's not real.
It's fun.
Right.
It's not a real thing for me.
I treated it like a real thing and I hustled my ass off and I made connections
and I worked in the reason that I could get so many people online if I just,
because his whole fucking tickets,
because I knew how the game was played,
I learned how to work with the judges.
I knew who was judging fights and how to score and how to deal.
And so all of that,
whereas a lot of coaches don't ever kind of get out of their own way.
They just,
they're so in their mantra of,
you know,
well I'm really good at what I do and you know,
this is traditional Thai boxing and this is how it should be scored.
No,
I'm,
every day I'm always adjusted.
We'd have fights like,
and hey,
you got a box man.
There's,
there's boxing judges,
other,
you've got a box.
Whereas maybe like we were in La,
I say,
oh,
did you know the,
the judges are more like ties,
so you can do that.
You can do your thing.
You know,
we've always adjusted.
Yeah.
So I think,
I think part of it is just,
it's,
it's drive,
it's hustle and it's its determination to be successful.
And that's,
you know,
for me,
that's,
that's what I have focused on with the gym and it's grown.
And like I said,
we started at one location we had,
it was 3,500 square feet.
I had zero students and then five,
three years we had 400 that's crazy.
It's hard to get a hundred students.
Yeah,
no.
Especially in Jujitsu schools,
Jujitsu schools,
that's the number.
That's the magical number.
You have a hundred students now you're making x amount per month cause you had a
hundred people paying x amount per month.
It's actually make a living.
It's the diversity.
Right.
So what happens is,
is that when people find out that maybe MMA isn't for them,
they can go into my fitness program.
When people find out that maybe fitness isn't for them,
they can go into my crop,
my God program,
they find out the crop,
isn't it for them.
And,
and the bottom line is also as,
I don't treat it like any kind of bullshit.
He have a tree crop McGaw program.
I do have a huge gramma got program huge of that program.
And it's the same thing.
It's like,
oh,
we do Krav Maga.
Listen,
all Krav Maga is,
is combat sports.
That's a little,
that's,
yeah,
I'm a fan of crop.
My God,
what crop [inaudible] guys is martial arts and that's it.
It's like they've just,
they've just developed self defense scenarios and they use real martial arts.
That's it.
And gave me real karate,
real Judy.
We do it and we do it even more combat sports that from all of my Kravis have to
go through grappling classes.
All the [inaudible] have to learn our combos,
the crop and got themselves Kravis it,
that's the term is crop.
It's promised.
But like if any Kravis dignitaries,
but
I have taught,
did watch teach Krav Maga to the uh,
uh,
the Bolivian secret service.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's good.
I didn't even know the story.
That won't sound that garden coke.
Yeah,
but narco shit.
That's what,
that's why I guarantee you do listen to this podcast is going to be a bunch of
profiles.
This is mother fucker.
Just say he doesn't charge
some more tie in California,
I'm paying two 50 a month for my gym.
What is going on?
Well,
yeah,
run down the list and,
and the percentage of the purse and then the sponsorships and all that pad work.
And then I remember one time this Jim,
I heard a friend from a gym that there were pain,
you know,
like $300 a month and like painting and like I,
I grew up with him so I don't know that I was like Karen,
you wouldn't believe
going on over
there.
Robbing them,
pay money for work.
It is Fliss
of you.
Very impressive.
I'm very impressed by that.
I think that's amazing.
You look,
you get a lot of Kudos in the combat sports world,
but I think that might be one where you deserve the most.
That's very,
very impressive.
That's incredible.
Oh,
and I love these kids.
I mean this is my son.
You do.
I know you and I do.
And Zoya.
That's my daughter and Kevin.
That's my son and Stephanie and Ed,
so you know,
it,
it becomes a family and that's the thing.
It's like these people so I can get all the time.
It's like,
oh,
what do I need to do to train at CSA?
You need to move there.
Do you have dorms?
Nope.
I don't have dorms.
You want to train with me?
You got to move here and you got to,
and you've got to want it.
Dorms is when it gets sketchy.
You got a bunch of Weird dudes living in your gym.
No boy.
But you gotta really,
really,
really want to train with me because you got to figure out where to live.
You got to figure out what to do.
Like Diego Llamas,
Gloria kickboxing fighter,
he showed up when the he,
he messaged Kevin one time.
I think from what I hear the story,
it was just me and Kevin doesn't reply that like,
I don't know,
like he hasn't replied to just anybody like that either.
We're talking a little bit,
it's like,
oh yeah,
you should come down like you know,
for a couple of weeks,
whatever shows up as a,
hey,
I just moved here to the doors from Mexico,
brought his wife,
got shut down as gym.
Yeah,
I just moved here.
Yeah.
You told me I had to move here.
So it's part of the team now.
What does that feel like to you?
Because that's heavy responsibility,
man.
Listen,
listen man.
Here,
here's my philosophy is this is when a fighter wins.
They did their job when a fighter loses.
I didn't.
And it's just that simple.
It's literally that simple.
It's not that
he could have helped them out to me.
So right now let's say you train the guy who fights Anderson.
So I'll use no use Alexis.
Alexis,
fuck Caitlyn.
And I thought it bottom line.
I think Alexis won that fight.
I can see why she didn't.
She wears her fights on her face.
Like,
you know,
like Zoya
does like literally if you blow it Alexis,
she's,
she swells up was a very close fight.
Exactly.
But if you,
if you look at her the wrong way,
she's gonna Swell up.
Right.
And I know that.
So for me,
w w the game plan was very simple,
very specific.
There were pieces of the game plan that worked.
The right leg kick moved her where we needed to move her to the left body kick
was also part of the game plan to take away what we needed.
Alexis wasn't throwing it,
Alexis didn't throw it.
Whose fault is that?
Mine or Alexis?
In my mind it's my fault because I didn't see that that wasn't going to happen.
She's throwing it in and other fights.
So what did I do wrong?
How did I miss that half of the game plan that would have won this fight very
easily in my opinion,
a hundred percent.
Yeah.
Um,
it didn't happen.
I can sit back and be mad at the fighter or I can sit back and say,
you missed this in training.
You need to figure out how to avoid this.
You need to learn from it.
And that's what I do every single fight.
When you're watching fights at home and he see like a guy,
one of the things that drives me nuts,
what I'm doing commentary like see a guy start to soften some dude off with leg
kicks,
starts to get that leg buckling a little bit and then inexplicably they stopped.
But there's a reason they stopped their own it.
They're,
they're not,
they're not conditioning their shin and they're hurting themselves.
The a hundred percent of the thing,
or it could be they heard him with a right hand and they got,
they got punch happy that too.
But most of the time when I see people stop kicking on a leg kick that works,
it's because they're feeling it and they're like two because they don't
condition their shins properly.
That's why I've talked to people about it and there's,
so for me,
you're absolutely right.
You rock somebody with the right hand,
you go head hunting hundred percent.
Um,
but a lot of the time people do not condition their legs.
They don't,
you know,
now you've got everybody going after the calf kick and if you don't know how to
throw a calf kick and if you don't know how to deal with,
if you after a calf kick,
invariably you're going to catch shin a lot of the time.
So if you're not conditioning your leg,
you okay,
you land a couple of calf kicks.
But uh,
you know,
when you talk about mighty mouse,
he landed a beautiful calf kick in that first round.
That's what hurt Henry.
But he kept,
he caught some Shin to and I guarantee you that didn't help as broke his foot.
That didn't help.
Yeah.
Mighty mouse broke his foot and that fight,
he's got videos of it on right now.
It's a side of,
it was,
I struggled and,
and,
and that's very easy to do if you know how to check.
Literally,
if you check properly,
you want to care of a calf cakes at all.
I know.
I'm just going to check it.
Like I might eat one like match Chanel for example,
that he comes down and he trains with us.
He loves to throw a calf kicks.
And I'm like,
all right,
throw it.
Like I'm just going to just going to check it every time and I'll counter
properly.
If you know how to check a leg kick and you know how to check a calf kick,
you're going to hurt the person doing it 100% of the time.
What do you recommend for Qi?
Shin conditioning?
Um,
nothing crazy progressive.
A dense contact.
So starting with a heavy bag and then a more densely packed heavy bag.
And then eventually you can get to sand bag.
Yeah.
And that's what we do.
We've got three different levels of bag in the gym and we've got standard bag,
densely packed bag and then sandbag.
Sandbag.
Yeah.
Damn.
Who makes it sandbag?
Nobody does you make it?
You,
Kevin,
eight hours.
Eight hours.
Yeah.
So just go to the hardware store?
Yeah,
no kick in sticks or anything like that.
So what do you,
uh,
how do you know what kind of line or do you use to fill up with sand?
So it's a standard uses.
So you can put a liner in or if you've got a really good bag,
then you know it'll be okay.
But you put in basically a garbage bag,
a a well done garbage bag,
lawn contractor,
and then,
and then you don't want to go just sand.
It's still stuffing,
stuffing and sand,
stuffing and sand.
And then you build from there and then it'll be denser at the bottom and then
you start kicking higher and then you work your way down the bag.
And it's not even about cracking it,
it's just about conditioning the Shin as evenly as possible.
Just deadening it up and putting those little calcium deposits all over evenly
as possible.
That's why I'm not a big fan of the rolling and the,
and the hitting and because all you're doing is you're just,
you're,
you're creating these little micro breaks and fractures in variable spots.
It's not spreading across the Shin the same way when you'd have a kicking target
like a bag.
And it also seems like if you're throwing kicks,
it's going to be a more realistic application.
You know,
it's like the fashion kicks on something and hardening your shins up.
Just seems.
I've seen guys do that with like coke bottles,
you know,
I've seen all that stuff.
It just doesn't,
no one ever doesn't work.
I know.
I've never done that in my life.
Really?
Yeah.
But you use that sandbag a sandbag.
How often you use it?
Well,
especially I used to even more so when I have a Thai or kickboxing fights coming
up,
but I'll use it every day.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It just doesn't have to be something that's hours and hours at a time.
Drills and you know,
it's amazing how much that low calf kick has made its way into MMA and how much
it changes.
Fights.
Yeah.
And timebox Benson Henderson was the first one to use it back then when he was a
champion.
Even before that,
in Thai,
boxing is considered kind of dirty and you know.
Yeah.
That's why I don't see it as much in boxing or dirt.
A little dirty.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's why you don't see it that much.
It's like,
ah,
you know,
it's low hanging fruit.
It's cheap.
It works.
Absolutely.
Why would it be?
That's it's weird how Paul the Thai boxing is corn is different in Thailand and
in here.
Well,
you know,
for the longest time when Jujitsu leg locks were dirty and people would go crazy
if you went for a leg block,
they would blue until you released it.
People would scream at you.
Coaches would say,
just let it go.
Just let it go.
Let the leg lock go.
Ricardo was had that leg log,
uh,
and his fight regarding Ramos,
I it was d the only thing is he made,
he tried to make that adjustment and go behind the armpit and they,
I just got off.
It's just he was doing it like they were grappling.
Yeah.
You know,
which is a thing that people do.
Do you know,
you forget that the guy can just stand up like you,
that he's going to stay engaged with you.
Yeah.
It's a common mistake that people do,
but he just made an adjustment and you know,
the guy who fought was good man.
It was a close fight fight.
Very,
very good match up there.
You could match up like there was a lot of those Saturday night.
There's a lot of like really good ones.
The last one in the prelims I was,
I was there at the fights.
Is it my car?
No,
no,
no.
The prelims.
That wasn't in the prelims.
No,
no,
that wasn't the main card.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
That's right.
Yeah.
Ruts.
Right.
Cub Swanson,
Jesus Christ.
More coddled.
Look good.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
The Jab.
But he's a fucking real technician man.
He's big for each other.
Wait.
Yeah.
For 45 11 and butt looks big and when you're standing next frame,
he's 170 pounds and he's in the inside.
The actual case itself,
Dude,
he's just very technical man.
Like everything he does,
he's,
there's no sloppiness to them.
Like everything.
And then can we kill it?
It dropped him with a jab.
I mean it looks like he hit him with a fucking straight right hand on the
button.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
Well that's cub Watson couples coming in at the same time do it,
which is true,
but he's so long and they stiff arm.
It's just,
it was,
it was the way it snapped in there too.
It was just perfect.
Perfect timing.
And then to take cubs back that quick and get them in that rear naked choke like
that.
Like wow.
Massive white candles.
No joke.
I'm standing up.
The level of talent is so high right now.
It's really fascinating because there's guys that aren't even in the top 15 that
looked like world champions from 10 years ago.
Yeah,
it's really interesting.
no,
the,
the adaption is,
I say it all the time.
Again,
I'm known as a Moyie Thai coach,
but the best movie time strikers,
you know,
don't have the best success in UFC striking.
You know,
it's,
it's so,
you know,
the most decorated best Muay Thai guys and Gals,
Joanna,
you know,
you have to put her up there.
Valentina,
you have to put up there.
These are legit world champions.
Not Somebody who went to Florida and when the Ikea of classic or something like
that.
But on the guy's side,
you look at like the two best Muay Thai guys ever.
Uh,
you know,
you,
you look at Shane Campbell and I don't know if you know Shane's background,
but Shane Campbell literally was a world beater and Moyie Thai from Canada,
his last fight with UFC,
he got dropped with a body shot and got cut because he could never really sit
down on his strikes cause it's always worried about the tickets.
And then there's a little gloves as well.
Exactly.
Hakeem Hakeem world beater and Moyie Thai world champion.
It was his first fight out.
He got 20 some odd seconds and got knocked out with,
well how about Saki?
Exactly right.
It's round trees.
A bad motherfucker.
No taken away from Roundtree and he hits hard but it's crazy watching go con get
cracked and knocked out with one shot.
It's like a little globes.
Definitely.
You have an out of the plane,
you have to respect the little gloves and you have to respect the other
influences in MMA.
Okay.
When,
and again I'm,
I'm probably one of the few coaches that'll like fixate on on losses and try to
really,
really learn from them.
When he,
you watched his second MMA fight where he lost right.
The guest on and he in that moment came out very slow twitch.
He was very almost McGregor.
Ascii was going through a little phase that I didn't pick up on in camp and he
comes out in this kid that he's fighting as a karate kid.
Super talented kid.
Right.
And literally the speed at which they were fighting stylistically was different.
He was in second gear and this kid was in fifth year.
You agree with us?
Yeah,
absolutely.
What was,
what was the motivation behind your changing of your style?
A bit.
Like I said,
I was going through a lot of that time and I just didn't want to start.
Yeah,
I remember like what?
Just walking out I just wasn't like focused.
Yeah.
Like I said,
like my last kickbox if I have the five before that,
I just felt even the spinning back elbow one I just felt at home.
I was like,
yeah,
you can see me smiling.
Like you know dude,
I just sitting back elbow might be the greatest spinning back elbow Kayo in the
history of MMA.
Thank you man.
That shit was ridiculous.
We played it on his podcast.
He's like,
you want to see it spinning elbow cause I heard about,
I heard you're talking about it with Kevin Lee to this.
Yeah.
When that elbow hit his jaw,
here it is budgetary.
Oh come on man.
I mean that that is,
that's the greatest spinning elbow of all time.
Like it just is.
I mean it can't get any better and he's done that yet.
Can't get better eight times.
It's done that eight times.
I'm not till I landing it.
I'm talking about finishing fights with that elbow,
but that's the best of all the ones he's,
in my opinion,
that's the best way to land charts.
That's the best word.
And I know when they're coming in you're for the force of their punch.
Let me say that one more time.
See I slipped the jab at the same time.
What?
You threw that kick first?
Yeah,
he's coming in with a slipping.
Oh my God.
He's not expecting it.
He's coming in with that with the strike and he's not expecting to get hit.
Dude,
that is so ridiculous.
But now everybody,
he changed,
he,
he literally changed when we tie in America.
He didn't invent that,
but it was the first time anybody saw it and amateur tournaments.
Now like in California,
you cannot throw a spinning elbow until after your fourth amateur fight because
of him.
Wow.
Because it's so deep.
It changed.
The game does so much damage.
It does so much damage and the way he throws it does damage.
Like if you see like John has thrown it,
like John Jones,
there was a,
but he hits the forearms because he throws it horizontally.
As tall as John Is.
If John wants to finish people with that elbow,
he needs to come down with it and he's the arc down and drop his weight.
Even if their shell,
he'll split down the middle.
The angle at which he throws.
If you're taller than him,
he's going to come underneath and you're shorter than him.
Are the same height.
Also throw it like at the same time as I'm throwing a right hand and I just go
through,
so I'll throw it either.
Either way.
I'll go either way.
Yeah.
He's knocked people out on both sides.
It's not just one side.
It's very,
very effective way.
I've always felt like the best people that transition from kickboxing to MMA or
the really explosive ones,
which is one of the reasons why cro cop did so well in MMA,
not just because he dedicated them to dedicated himself to it,
which was a huge factor,
but also because when you watch cro cop and k one he was a exploder.
He would like take pot shots at people and just,
he would have twitch.
Yeah,
and he would have a naked kick or a naked punch.
Like he,
he wasn't like a guy who is throwing a lot of technical stuff and setting things
up.
He would whack out of nowhere.
I throw full power full cause he was so fast.
And that translates extremely well to MMA in my opinion.
The pace of Moy,
Tai,
it can be a little slower.
Yeah.
So when you're dealing with like with his fight,
like I said,
he's coming in,
you know,
relaxed and,
and,
and slow twitch and thinking,
timing and bouncing a little bit.
And this kid is a karate kid and he's immediately,
like you said,
flip right.
You don't see it coming,
you get caught.
Right.
So that's where I think Stryker's that listen and no disrespect to that kid.
I think that kid is one of the best,
uh,
one of the Brandon,
I can't remember his last name,
one of the best of him.
His name is Brandon.
Um,
I forget his last name.
You don't remember him?
I can't,
I can't remember his last name.
Most people when they lose to that names etched in their fucking head forever.
Nah,
he let it go.
You got it.
You got to,
you got to let it go,
man.
You got to go.
But that kid,
he's,
he's tell you,
if you don't,
we'll find his name.
What's his name?
Jamie.
Just put look,
pull up.
Gaston's which should be insured though.
Norellco wired is Larocco.
Yeah.
That,
that kid isn't Uber talented kids.
I was very impressed by.
Absolutely.
And you know,
he might not have guessed ons.
Look,
you might not have some of what guests Dan brings to the table and he hasn't
really caught on since super talented kid.
He wasn't disrespected in that fight.
He just wasn't.
Uh,
he wasn't,
there was no film on him.
We didn't know who he was.
His style was not anticipated and he came out super slow and he got fucking con.
Do you may,
do you train much with karate stylists or someone who's got that?
Cause it seems to me that it's like when you have like a wonder boy Thompson
style there,
there's,
there's something to that.
You know,
there's something to that that's like,
it's very weird to deal with.
It's a different,
when people are Unorthodox in general,
it's just so hard to like really make Daniels is another one and it's hard to,
it's hard to really like get going with people like that.
And like uh,
like Karen was saying,
I come from a background like a five round Moitai fight is different and I got
normally and he can agree with me like my first few fights I take the first
round off.
I'm just like all right let's get going.
Let's see what he's got right.
It's like we have,
we got five rounds to work here.
Right.
That's where Kevin said the most trouble with kickboxing because,
because he's used to five rounds,
the first round is just of feel him
out.
You know?
And so as coaches it's our job to change that.
And that's what I struggle with that a lot with my tie guys.
Cause again,
I'll make legs Zoya I'll make guest on,
I have these guys fighting when we tie fights as well cause it's definitely
going to help your striking.
But if you fixate on that rhythm,
that foot work,
that timing and MMA,
that's where you're going to have the most trouble.
So those karate stylists are going to give you trouble and the wrestlers are
going to give you trouble cause you're never going to have to sit down on
anything.
Well Michael Van and page is probably one of the most exciting guys in del
towards his last fight to God,
not the boxing one.
No.
Then when they fight,
it was in March.
Oh my God,
he's a monster.
But it's that style.
Is that bully?
You ever see him fight Raymond Daniels and a point karate?
No,
I did it.
Some videos of them fighting on.
It's crazy.
They're sprinting at each other.
They're so fucking fast.
But I've said for a while that I think there's,
there's something really good to that,
that ability to blitz,
especially when you're dealing with little gloves and you know,
and,
and MMA rules.
I just think that there's,
that's a,
that's a really important skill that a lot of people don't have that ability to
blitz.
And if you have that sort of slow first round Thai style here,
here's the two of these guys.
I look at that with down,
I mean this is like fast twitch muscle or heaven.
I want to say this is,
yeah,
there it is.
Yeah.
So seven years ago they want to take,
he chose his so fast,
but they're trying to score points.
You know,
this is such a different game.
I,
I did a little bit of this stuff when I was competing.
It's so different.
The range is so it's beautiful to watch.
They stop it with every strike.
Oh they stop it.
Yup.
Every time you touch each other they stop it and they score a point.
So it's super unrealistic in terms of an actual fight and the,
the thought process behind it is nonsense.
The thought process was that you should be able to kill somebody with one punch
and then all you have to do is touch them and then stop.
That could have killed the guy.
It's,
it's nonsense.
But the benefit to it as much like the benefit of learning taekwondo early,
you learn taekwondo early because you develop leg dexterity that you would never
develop if you threw in leg kicks and punches and take downs and all those other
things.
It's very rare that someone goes through a,
just a,
a traditional martial arts bat or a traditional MMA background where you're just
learning everything.
Takedowns lay kicks off and you ever develop kicks the way someone who's like a
real high level taekwondo practitioner does,
but those taekwondo guys,
they have so many holes in their games because of that,
and this is the same thing with karate guys,
but that skill that these guys have of being able to touch each other the first,
I mean if you add all that other stuff,
like venom page has add submissions,
Adelaide kicks,
saddle it,
then you got a crazy combination.
Yeah,
that's,
that's part of what we've,
we've had a lot of success with in our striking is that,
yeah,
Moyie Thai,
but at the end of the day,
our boxing is,
we'll box,
it's western boxing,
you know,
we'll do Dutch combos.
We'll do Thai clinch tie elbows.
Um,
but we'll also adapt our striking for MMA.
And most Moitai coaches aren't really thinking how,
you know,
the MMA,
like you don't throw lake kicks when somebody is coming forward in an MMA fight,
you're going to get taken down.
They have to be backing up.
You have to stop them with something.
Most Thai coaches aren't going to go out of their way to learn the sport of MMA
to become an effective and an a striker,
right?
Cause all I'm more like,
like Saki.
Listen,
I know his,
uh,
round trees coach Jason Park,
um,
who's,
uh,
out of boxing works with Bryan Pope,
joy,
tremendous gym down here in southern California and go,
gone throws that blind light kick and he throws it from that side and it leaves
his head open.
They plan for that.
That was a planned counter.
That wasn't just luck of the draw.
That's an MMA coach with a solid Moyie Thai background.
Who's understanding,
um,
understanding,
striking for MMA versus someone like,
Oh God,
who again,
one of the best strikers to ever be in the UFC.
Who hasn't really adapted unlike a cro cop to MMA yet?
Well it's also go Kahn came into the UFC with how many fights?
I mean how many fights is that guy had and kickboxing times.
But how many MMA fights?
It was like,
oh one he came in.
Yeah,
I think he was all in one.
Yeah.
And that,
that's,
you know,
you'll get that a lot with people like Jermaine when,
when I first started training Germain de Randamie,
I'm the one that brought her over here.
She was owned one.
She got her arm broken by Vanessa Porto in a Florida fight.
Right.
And how are you pronouncing her last name?
Day Run.
Dommy is that all she says it?
Yeah.
Cause everybody says Deronn to me.
Yeah,
no,
they run dommy I've heard to say they're in dummy.
Yeah.
She just lets you still say it how they want,
but why did she decide enough?
Fight Cyborg.
What,
what was that all about?
Because she wanted a title beat Holly Holm and then said,
yeah,
you know,
fuck that.
I'm not dying.
That steroid sheet is basically what she said.
She called her a steroid sheet.
You're going to say what you're going to say in the moment.
Right.
So,
Eh,
you know,
when she,
when I met her,
she was,
she was Oh,
and one,
she was like the most dominant female kick boxer of all time,
dude.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I did.
Yeah.
The Dude,
she was training with the Sean Tompkins and then Sean passed away and her
manager at the time said,
hey,
she needs a place to go.
So brought her over.
Uh,
we met and uh,
helped her get her visa.
I got her signed with Strikeforce and uh,
uh,
she thought of that plate women.
Yeah,
it did a few different things in her and Miriam never really got along.
So I could see early on,
her and Miriam never sparred.
They drilled a couple of times,
never sparked once while I had both of them at the gym.
That seems kind of crazy.
Well then we're going to fast forward that over to the Cyborg thing at the end
of the day.
Um,
I feel like in that moment Jermaine achieved what she wanted to achieve and for
whatever reason,
whoever was advising her at the time,
I think she should have taken that fight.
I think she should have done that fight.
She wasn't with me at the time.
I can't judge what Cyborg.
Fine.
Yeah.
That's not what she had an injury apparently turned thumb.
And she,
she said,
I interviewed her after the Holly Holm fight.
Judge,
you need to get surgery on her thumb.
Correct.
But then she changed the story later and said she's never going to fight Cyborg.
I don't understand that.
I mean,
but you,
you,
if you're going to call her a cheat,
okay.
She was a cheap before you even went to the hundred 45 pound division,
you knew who inevitably this is what was gonna happen.
Right.
So I questioned that as a person.
Nice girl.
You know,
what do you think it is then?
I mean,
the only thing that I would say is she doesn't want to fight her because she
doesn't think she could beat her.
I think that,
I definitely think that that's got to be in somebody's head.
I can't say not,
but I can't say that it
not be,
she's fucking take when they,
like when they presented the Cyborg fight to me from Miriam,
I said yes right away.
I said,
yes,
we'll do it in kickboxing in Moitai.
Yes.
I would not have said yes and MMA.
It just would not have,
it's not going to go well.
It's,
it's just not for someone like that.
And Jermaine does not have enough experience in MMA.
If Jermaine is on her back,
she's not getting up.
She's just not.
Amanda Nunez showed that people show that she doesn't have that skill yet.
Right.
So just say,
Hey,
I'm not ready for this yet.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I can't say that when you're the world champion yet it,
I,
but I,
so how she,
she hasn't fought since,
since she beat Holly.
So she's talking about fighting again and like I said,
we're,
we're friendly.
I mean we,
you know,
there's no bad blood.
It just wasn't that thumb fixed.
I believe she did.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's just,
it wasn't a good fit for the gym,
you know,
for,
for her and I,
but she again,
she's still under contract.
She got the surgery.
Um,
I wish her,
well,
I think she's going back to 35 from what I understand.
If she can go to 35 she should because Cyborg camp.
So you seen that video of her cutting weight to sit next to her before I've
shook her hand.
She's gigantic.
She weighs a buck 85 if she weighs a pound.
I mean she's,
she's walking around very,
very heavy and thick and so she obviously died down,
gets into like one 70 pound range diets down a little bit more,
gets into one 65 pound range and then begins the dehydration process.
But she is fucking enormous when she gets into that cage.
Yeah.
Then the problem is California with that 10% rule,
there's no way she makes it,
there's no way she makes that.
I think that is just a recommendation though.
The first time it's a work sheet.
There's a couple of guys that uh,
the weight in the next day like heavier than the 10% and they would be
interested in,
didn't she fight in California though after the rule?
It will be interesting to know what she weighed in at all.
So that's very interesting because they don't give that information out.
I wish they would like boxing does like Hbo.
They'll show you read the cow.
Yeah,
that's,
that's cool.
I read the California,
I read yesterday that California was going to start releasing the fight day
weights.
Like foster that guy who's the head of the California State Athletic Commission.
He's on the ball.
That guy is on the ball.
He's so ahead of the curve and with all that Shit with implementation of
additional weight classes with uh,
with like catching people doing steroids with just,
I love that guy.
I'm a big fan.
No,
Andy.
Andy has been great for the sport in California and know when people talk about,
Oh,
Dana is going to change the way in times and this and this and this.
I don't believe that Andy Foster would let that happen in his lifetime with,
here's what I think.
If you're going to have this way in thing early in the morning,
let them weigh in all day till the fucking limit to,
if it's four o'clock in the afternoon where they're supposed to weigh in,
have it cut it off at three 30 so you know for sure whether or not someone's
going to make it,
but the problem is you,
you wake up at eight o'clock in the morning,
you only have two hours.
You're that's not the same as being able to do it all throughout the day where
your body would normally just lose a little bit of weight anyway.
It changes,
it changes everything.
That timing and that's,
that's where you know,
you look at the numbers,
it was like,
oh you know,
two year span before they changed the timing.
X amount of people missed weight to your span sense.
This many people in this bullshit,
they do push,
you give him more time and they are going to push it if they know that they can
rehydrate longer,
which is the idea is that it's safer because you can rehydrate from 8:00 AM to
4:00 PM instead of,
you know from 4:00 PM on.
I just think that give them all the time they need,
you know,
and fuck one fcs laid out the groundwork.
Just look at what they did with their rehydration tests and or hydration test
rather.
And implement cutting weight is just silly.
Like I was talking to my girlfriend about it and she was like,
wait,
you guys,
she didn't know much about fighting at the time,
you know,
obviously,
but she was like,
you guys make this weight but the next day you're not.
You're not the same way,
so why not just not weigh in?
Yeah,
I guess stupid.
It's just like,
it sounds really stupid.
That's not what you find that it's sanction cheating.
Yeah.
Sanction cheating is cheating at a much higher scale even than PDS.
If you get two people when they both weigh one 35 but they're both,
uh,
you know,
they're both totally hydrated and one of them has been doing steroids and one of
them hasn't been doing steroids.
The difference will be far less than if one person weighs in at one 35 but then
balloons up to one 60 and then gets into that octagon at one 60.
But there's no PDDs involved.
Well,
that's a much greater advantage.
someone who's doing some,
some sort of a testosterone thing or something,
especially with the,
with more time now to rehydrate,
it's still not enough time.
Right,
right.
You know,
the 48 hours,
you know,
whatever the current is compromised there,
you're absolutely cost the benefit might outweigh the benefit of being so much
larger might outweigh being compromised.
Oh,
absolutely.
And B,
and if you look at the previous record,
it was,
you know,
a losing record for fighters that Miss,
wait when it was a five o'clock way in and now it's a winning record for
fighters that Ms. Wade and an 11:00 AM Wayne because they have more time
to recover.
Dude,
if I running shit,
I would fix that first.
That would be the first thing I would fix.
The next thing I'd fix is judging the idea that you have wind bonus and loss
bonus,
but you haven't fixed the fucking judging his God damn crazy.
It's crazy.
It I just throw my hands up sometimes now I can't even say anything anymore
because I've had so many rants about it and they've gone nowhere.
Nothing gets done,
and you still have people that literally have never applied an Armbar in their
life.
They've never taken a punch in the face in their life.
They've never thrown a kick in competition in their life and they're judging
these fights and they don't even train.
I mean,
even forget competition.
Just fucking have a love of the sport.
They don't even have a love of the support.
They're just doing it as a job.
It's crazy.
It is crazy when you have a limited supply or an unlimited rather,
an unlimited supply of people who are martial arts experts who would make
fantastic judges all throughout the world.
You have so many thousands of them.
Yeah.
I mean,
how many fucking people are giant martial arts fans that are on,
whether it's sure dog or mixed martial arts.com or you know,
fill in the name of the website.
There's so many people that are in engrossed in martial arts all day long.
That's what they live for.
And they Jill debate whether or not so Hutto should a one round two or mighty
mouse show wanted with effective striking.
And there's like this real comprehensive conversation going on.
These people that are judging the fight can even have that conversation.
If you had a conversation with half the fucking UFC judges.
If I had them here and I sat them down and I said,
you know,
let's,
let's watch a fight and you tell me what you is going on here,
but tell me what you think is better.
Tell me what you think.
How hard,
what,
what does a low calf kick feel like?
You know what it,
what does it feel like when you get hit with a liver shot?
You know what,
when,
when is a guy safe in a triangle and when is he in danger?
How can you protect yourself?
Who's dom,
who's dominating what position?
What does a guy just laying on top to breathe and the rest and the third round
or when they're,
they like doing damage.
Recognize,
can you recognize the progression?
Do you understand what a guy has to do to get out of the out of the guard?
Do you understand what a guy has to do to escape from an arm triangle?
If you don't,
you have no fucking business putting these guys livelihoods and their records
and literally half their earning.
You have no business.
Half the fucking money.
If you have a,
if you're getting 50 and 50 this motherfucker costs you $50,000 by not knowing
anything.
That is insane to me.
That should be fixed.
And why is there three judges?
Why three says who cause boxing's always done it that way.
What do we fucking copycats?
That doesn't make any sense.
We should have five and have five judges.
You have a much greater chance of getting it right with five judges.
Have five judges.
Make these motherfuckers take tests.
First of all,
that's,
that's one thing.
Second,
why 10 point must system.
What the fuck is that?
That's some boxing shit.
Why are you using a boxing scoring system for something that involves takedown
submissions,
leg kicks,
punches,
elbows,
knees.
Like there's too many things.
There's way too many things.
It's,
it's a crazy system.
Absolutely.
This is what I get the,
the most,
the discussions for Moy Tai.
It's the same thing.
That means it's the same exact same exact problem.
Same problem.
It's not there.
You know,
what's,
what's worth more?
What's not worth putting judge in Thailand?
Um,
well it,
it depends.
Now in Thailand they're starting to just kind of score things evenly cause
they're wanting to get to just three,
three minute rounds.
Yeah.
They want to do,
they want Muay Thai in the Olympics.
Right?
So you can't score the body kick more than a leg kick in the Olympics.
Right.
The weapons have to be equal is what they want from the,
the International Olympic Committee.
And also cause it used to be like,
oh,
you know,
I've been to Thailand three times and I'll go to Lund,
piney or Raja and you know,
these guys were like,
and sometimes it would be foreigners.
Frank's fighting against ties and like there was like punch and you know,
and do all this low cakes and stuff like that.
And then [inaudible] with two body kicks in,
they'll win the round because the body kit scores more.
Right.
And the tie score,
I mean it's designed for gambling,
right?
So it's,
it's one of those things where,
you know,
people scream,
it's not traditional ties,
not traditional Thai.
It's not traditional Thai.
At the end of the day,
no one's saying that traditional ties,
right.
Either the body kicks should not be worth more than a punch to the mouth.
I believe they've changed it now they have everything.
Everything else.
This is damage damage,
right?
Hard shot.
It's hard shots versus,
you know,
but isn't that subjective?
Like what is a hard shot and what's not a harsh?
It is.
It is here,
but especially because it's the ABC,
Adelaide bird judged Kevin's fight with your motto.
She did so,
yeah.
Nice Lady.
That's what I was saying about Adelaide.
Yeah,
that's it.
I always smile when I see here.
It was like a load.
I remember that.
Or remember that fight drives me crazy though.
Yeah,
and literally it's my,
my opinion is that she gave the fight to your model because I guarantee you she
didn't know that elbows were supposed to mean more just because Kevin was
bleeding and that's all she could see.
I remember it was my 21st birthday.
I walked,
I walked off because I thought Kevin One and then I'm like,
wait,
what just happened?
Yeah.
Literally there was one around where,
I mean there was one round where he threw seven body left,
body left body kicks in,
a row answered,
just boom,
boom,
boom.
And he had some blood on him and he lost the fight.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
Yeah.
Unreal.
It's unfortunate and it's,
it's,
it's not this the,
here's the thing I've been saying this forever.
Nothing changes.
Yeah.
You know what?
I was really surprised at this past weekend,
I was talking to Daniel Cormier and I said,
I think the stupidest fucking rule is that 12 to six elbow,
and he said,
I like that rule.
And I said,
really?
I said,
you don't think that 12 to six elbow should be legal.
He goes,
you ever get hit by a 12 and six elbow on the ground?
I said,
no,
I haven't.
And he said
he didn't believe me,
man.
It sucks.
I go,
but doesn't every elbow on the ground suck?
Yeah.
I mean I would think that just getting hit this way,
you know,
just a,
a regular elbow sucks on the ground.
Your head's planted.
You're not going anywhere.
You're just taking these,
it isn't legal and Moitai either from,
from the clinch when you're going 12 to six I believe.
Not Legal.
No,
no,
no.
It's not like you can in the air.
Right.
You can jump up in the u s in the u s the 12 to six elbow because it's ABC.
Just he,
a video of him leaping through the air,
literally climbing the tree,
elbowing someone in the back of the head with it and he's like,
this doesn't count because when you're in the air,
digital becomes analog.
He sent me,
this is ridiculous.
I saw that.
I saw that explanation.
Miriam's fight,
and if my,
she ended up getting her fight.
She was the gold medal fight.
She ended up getting it moved to the king's Cup at the,
this was happening at the same time as the world championships just because she
was landing so many 12 to six flying elbows on girls.
They'd never seen it from a woman before and she was going crazy.
Yeah,
I mean literally just flying with,
just across the ring,
just chopping girls down with 12 to six elbows.
Her performance,
that was like Oh nine that performance on that.
He just run through girls like scary and that 12 to six elbow,
it's no more dangerous.
The most dangerous elbow and all of a combat sports as a spinning elbow.
That's the most dangerous.
How the fuck could it 12 to six elbow would be more powerful than other.
There's no,
there's no more dangerous elbow.
A Tyler toner,
the kid that he landed it on first,
the Dwayne's kid,
uh,
he is a pseudo veteran.
He's a UFC veteran.
It wouldn't cause a horrible broken orbital.
He retired.
I mean never fought again because I started to sink into it has to put a plate
on the bottom.
Cause yeah,
the broken orbital was so weird because oftentimes it changed the way the eye
looks like.
You remember when Bob Sapp well,
I think he has a lazy eye now.
Yeah,
he does not cro.
Cop Broke Bob saps eyeball.
Like he punched his eyeball through the back of his head where the orbital,
you know,
there's a,
there's a hole right where the eyeballs sits.
Like you see that thing?
Yeah.
He was fractured behind it.
And so now Bob's got one eye that's bays and whatnot.
It's little from getting tagged by Cro cop.
The 12 to six elbow.
It has no more effect than any other,
the straight left hand with boxing gloves on.
That's how hard cro cop hits.
Yeah.
Think about that shit.
It was a bad dude man.
Yeah,
he was a bad motherfucker until it still is.
And um,
the thing though is that it just,
it just doesn't make any sense to me that like,
like here's one that people are trying to,
to say that should be banned,
that side kick to the knee or the oblique kick to the knee.
That,
how has that,
why would you ban that?
We don't ban heel hooks.
Like that seems crazy to me.
Why would you ban that?
What you don't ban wheel kicks?
Like,
it's okay to literally bounce your heel off someone's head when you're spinning
your body around like a top and you have unbelievable power,
like
a wheel kick.
Like,
remember that when Terry Adam got knocked out by Edson Barboza like God,
he just,
he,
oh,
the air and just drop it was literally like someone hit his switch.
Just might be the best like spinning kick I've seen it was the first ever we'll
kick Keoni UFC.
Yeah,
and I mean we've,
we've had a few since then,
but it's just not such a crazy technique.
Yeah.
You got that.
Here it is.
Watch this rose and put it on the commentary
that was literally saying take a chance and risk getting knocked out.
And Terry,
Adam got knocked out.
Yeah.
I mean that shit was borrows on,
man.
It was a bad dude.
He's a bad motherfucker.
One of my favorite fights of him was when he fought.
Oh,
at the end Jack Wani.
that's fine.
That was a great fight.
That was,
I think that's my favorite stand up fight.
Quan.
He's just such a great kick boxer himself.
Muay Thai fighter.
He's doing now.
He's,
he's,
his last fight was Moyie Thai,
so he's all my time now.
He's always doing that.
Yeah.
He,
he won.
He won the triumphant.
Is his brother Moy Thai fighting as well?
He's a cutie Chitty is doing,
uh,
I think he cheated.
Might be in that tournament.
It was he,
who is he?
I don't know.
No Chinese seem to bind you sign with Bella tour.
No,
but he's not making one 78.
He's fighting one 85 this Bella toward doing Michael Page versus a Semtex Paul
daily.
Are they going to do that?
Yeah,
they're doing it.
They're doing.
And then they're in opposite brackets of a Musashi and uh oh good Lord.
Beltour reveals a welter weight tournament bracket including Michael Page versus
Paul Daley.
So page versus dailies on one side and this side is Musashi.
Got To fight at one 70.
Wait a minute,
that's not real,
right?
[inaudible] he's fighting once.
No,
Rory is going up to fight.
Musashi just announced today.
Okay.
This is so ori and Musashi up to weight loss is a big one.
85 or make that larger again so I can see what this is.
This is really strange.
So what they're doing is they're going to do Rory macdonald is Stan versus
chide.
So Rory Macdonald's staying in this welterweight Grand Prix as well.
If I need to do it [inaudible] September 29th then Lorens Larkin's still in the
mix too.
He's an alternate.
He's a nice man.
Lorens Larkin is a fucking beast.
You know,
mean he lost to Lima and then he got stopped by daily.
But
he's a monster and Korskoff man looked.
Did you see that with spinning back kick?
The korotkoff landed.
He literally sent that dude flying through the air.
I fought on that card.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
And Douglas Lema looks like a heavy weight.
It looks like a heavyweight.
Like you.
Like how the fuck is that guy won 70 he's gotta be one of the bigger weight
cutters in this sport.
Right?
Absolutely.
See,
this is what I'm thinking when I'm looking at this.
I'm like,
this is a really good tournament.
Like bell tours getting really close when you got lima.
Who's worldclass?
Korotkoff worldclass
we saw that when he fought Benson Henderson for sure.
Right.
But Lima stopped him and then he got Paul Daley who literally can stop anybody.
That motherfucker lands that left hand.
He can put anybody to sleep.
He knocked out.
It's going to be a banger.
Fuck yeah.
And Rory Mcdonald who shut Paul Daley Down,
you know,
and also beat Lima.
And then you got John Fitch,
who seems are reborn,
you know,
after he beat Paul Daley.
Very interesting,
right?
It's a good tournament plus very little drug testing.
We're California based Joe.
We don't know about all that.
Yeah,
fuck man.
What are you,
what are you talking about?
Yeah,
but it's,
it's fascinating.
You see the difference between guys in the early days of the UFC when he was the
wild west versus now.
I mean,
bodies have changed.
Careers have taken different paths.
Listen,
I'm a,
I'm a fan.
If,
if it's not legal then it should all be illegal.
And I'm a fan of Usada.
They visit my gym.
Somebody,
a poor Lexus has been tested like in two months.
I think they came up four times.
I asked her so much.
I Dunno.
Operate on rumors.
Nah,
no,
no.
Alexis,
if you look at Alexis Davis,
she's not someone that somebody thinks.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like that's why it's just because the Usada rep is very active in that area.
So they're like,
she's coming.
She's tested.
Todd,
she's tested Dustin and she's tested Alexis a lot.
Todd Todd Duffy.
She's tested a lot.
Todd Duffy was on testosterone replacement at one point in time before my time.
I believe so.
Well he was when he was like 25 it was,
he wasn't,
yeah,
it wasn't.
He's,
he's been,
he's been with me now for like the past year.
I renegotiated his UFC agreement.
I love Todd.
He was fun.
Great Guy.
Todd Todd as a heavyweight was fighting for like 10 and 10.
Uh,
well before I renegotiated his deal,
but he just had shoulder surgery and he just had knee surgery so we're hoping to
get him.
He had knee surgery.
Yeah.
Aw Man.
It's shoulder and knee surgery.
He had soldier surgery like six years,
six months ago.
He's still young though,
right?
You is too.
He's not the,
he's not that old.
I think mentally he thinks he's a good dude.
Yeah.
I as a heavyweight,
I can him being heavy with me being the federal way we can train together and
spar and he's just so controlled and soak in,
so that's awesome.
So quick for a heavy,
we don't,
we don't spar hard.
Yeah,
we really don't.
You don't know it don't,
not at all.
No.
The hardest I spar format,
that's fine.
Was probably when Cody came down there when I went up there.
That was twice and no we don't,
we don't really know.
I don't have smart heart.
That is so fucking smart.
And I love hearing that because I just feel like so many fighters make that
mistake.
Yeah,
well you covered with a boxing background.
You spar like three days a week at least to write and you're going,
you know,
you're going as hard as you can.
Uh,
and then you know,
Eh,
kickboxing,
you know,
ties.
They don't spar that hard,
but they'll go,
oh well you know,
they're done fighting or whatever.
But the truth of the matter is,
is that with all of the weapons that you have in and all the weapons such we're
having Thai boxing,
you're sparring hard with those weapons.
The chance of injury is checking through the roof.
If you're throwing spinning elbows and training,
it's full clip.
I can show you and I use,
I use him as the example is other people call them a coach.
If I don't,
if I don't throw this hard,
how am I going to know that I can land it in a fight?
Hard.
Well Guess John's never put anybody down with a spinning elbow in the gym and he
can land it in a fight and it's bullshit and I can,
I can show it really well,
like in the gym,
like to the point that I'm like right there and I just stopped.
I'm like,
I just liked him and I just raised my hand.
that would have been it.
Most people are looking at,
mostly people are draining like that.
Ya Know,
we,
we've never been a hard sparring gets one of the more controversial debates.
Right.
Whether or not you should spar hard,
it's really the thing you have to,
I absolutely,
some people thinks you have to,
I disagree with,
for us.
I disagree.
I listened to the hiring people to try to knock out George.
Yes.
I,
I get that and uh,
I understand it.
I don't agree with it.
I just don't,
the human body is fragile,
man.
The heat of the brain is fragile.
You cannot condition an Oregon.
Right?
But how can you argue with his success rate?
I mean,
it's really interesting.
It's like he's Look Aka who the fuck's bars harder than Aka.
Those guys are animals.
They'd go at each other.
But look,
Luke Rockhold world champ,
Daniel called me a world champ.
Cain Velasquez,
world champ could number Numberg Madoff world champ and a fucking litany of
assassins just waiting in the wings.
Yeah,
you mean in my opinion,
succeeding in spite of not because.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's certainly a debate and your opinion is very well respected.
And I,
I am on your side.
I like the idea of,
I think you know how to fight and what you're really doing is sharpening up
your,
your reaction times and your techniques and ingraining those paths,
right?
You're in grading those reaction paths.
And I don't necessarily think that the way to do that is to go full clip,
but I think oftentimes when you do that,
it actually makes you have less options inside the cage because your so like
wound up and tight and when you're sparring that way,
you're fighting Robbie Lawler.
Stop sparring for a while.
He stopped spar for like seven years.
I mean,
yeah,
you develop.
I have people that come to the gym and again,
when it,
when it comes to stand up,
only you know,
I'll put our record and our people against anybody in North America and we don't
spar heart and I get people to come to the gym all the time coming from a hard
sparring background and they are missing weapons.
They are missing tools.
They are in a fight or flight mode right away you are developing that sniper
bite down on your mouthpiece I attitude,
which is one attribute of fighting.
Sometimes you do need to bite down on your mouthpiece but it doesn't work out
for at least one of the two people doing it in a fight.
Yeah.
I like what you just said.
It's one attribute of fighting.
Absolutely.
It is one,
I mean you can't deny that it is one,
but it is only one and technical proficiency is the most important.
Being able to,
you know,
throw a jab,
established Jeb stablish pros use to fake some faints movement and being
defensively sound and have that incredible variable repertoire.
And that was one of the things you saw in the fight with Cody versus Tj.
Tj had a bigger toolbox.
Yeah.
You know,
in terms of his movement.
I mean,
he was more fluid while he was doing it,
you know,
and that ultimately proved to be what was most important in that fine,
I'll,
I'll 100% go to the grave believing that Cody is a far better boxer than Tj.
Um,
that didn't translate into an MMA fight on Saturday night for whatever reason.
you know,
and whether it's anger or whether it was the last fight,
whether it was game plan,
lack of coaching,
what,
whatever it was.
Um,
but 100%,
I believe that,
you know,
Cody did not show who or what he is that,
have you worked with Cody?
No.
What'd you want to,
I'm sure I worked with any,
but I'll work with anybody that has a good attitude and is willing to embrace my
way of doing because I think he's a very talented guy and I think he could
really benefit from training with someone like you.
Yeah,
I uh,
again,
and I think that,
uh,
the relationship that we're developing with Alpha Male,
they've got a ton of great guys.
There is a good one.
Um,
but I'm careful not to overstep my bounds.
You know what,
I don't say,
Hey,
I could fix you.
Come on over here.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do that.
The guys there that want to work with me,
I'm,
I happily work with and they allow my guys to go up there and wrestle,
which is what we need.
So it's been a good fit,
but I would never poach anybody.
Good for you,
man.
Good for you.
Yeah,
that's a,
yeah.
You don't want that bad blood.
Not that bad Juju on you definitely know.
So what Colin,
going forward with a,
your camp and with your career,
what are you guys doing now?
That's different than you have done in the past.
You have you added anything in terms of strength and conditioning or recovery or
anything that you find really beneficial?
Um,
strength and conditioning is always been something that we've done really well
for,
for us.
Um,
you know,
recently over the last couple of years,
we,
we added a,
Darren I think is really kind of the Darren who you 2 million people listen to
it,
but the bone crusher that we've added,
we've added the bone crusher.
He's our head MMA coach.
I'm his striking coach.
Um,
but what he's brought to the table for us on Instagram to watch oh absolutely
likes guns.
He does such a,
such an incredible Iq when it comes to fighting and then it made so much
knowledge and so many things.
Like sometimes you can agree,
like sometimes you click with people and like that's what happens between me and
him.
Like I only like rolling with him really because he,
uh,
he'll get me in positions that I'm going to probably be in a fire,
but he'll
like walk me through them at the same time versus like,
just like,
oh,
like it's different deliberate.
Right.
Learning curve for a striker and they're two different languages.
That's why the grapplers have trouble striking.
The strikers have trouble grappling.
Someone like Darren who can do both,
that can take a kid like Aston and can walk him through the positions,
the right choices,
the wrong choices in the moment while he's doing it is very rare that I have
found in Darren,
you know,
again,
he half Gracie black belt,
a few of the world champion,
but he started out working the front desk at fair techs.
So he's been around grappling.
Alex Gong is his idol,
you know,
that's his brother from a,
I mean,
so,
um,
you know,
we checked off bucket lists for Darren and he's done two muy Thai fights at a
pro level now.
Uh,
you know,
just pro Moyie Thai and he's done well.
Yeah,
I've been following.
It's interesting to watch and it's one of those things where he wants to shoot
boxing now and wants to go back to Japan and whatever he wants to do,
I'm going to support them in.
But his knowledge of the entire MMA game has helped our gyms so much.
And our fight team,
I mean,
I think in the UFC our win rate is like 78%.
You know,
Matt,
Dustin,
Alexis,
all these people came to us off of losing records.
You know,
Dustin lost two in a row.
He's about to get cut and that lost three in a row.
Alexis had lost two in a row.
Um,
we have a lot of people text and look fantastic.
And his last fight,
dusted kid came out of nowhere.
What a crazy angle.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like the handle was up and then it's still just went through and through the
hand.
So there's also,
the angle was like,
it was like a 45 degree head.
Dustin's flexibilities in that.
Great.
So that's the kick we work on.
He can't turn it over the sun highway stretch.
Well he does.
He does,
but absolutely.
Absolutely.
But from a flexibility standpoint,
and he's been doing that for so long,
can throw that kick the way he throws it.
So we embraced it because it's kind of like an off speed pitch.
That's one that he like slowed it down and then boom.
That's exactly what mark del Grande's said.
That's exactly what he said when he described it.
We talked about it the other day.
Yeah.
So and again,
that's why,
you know,
we talk about people switching,
like you know,
when,
when we talk about Mateus his opponent,
I remember his last name.
Um,
you know,
we knew what a great boxer he was,
but whenever he went south paw,
he didn't do anything.
Southby didn't Dustin do some work with that?
Sand Dunes?
Stepper does all the time.
All the time.
It does all this all the time.
I've got that thing here now.
Yeah.
Know Dustin swears by it.
He loves that thing every day.
That is a crazy what for people that don't know him,
don't know what it is.
They sent me one on the sand dunes stepper.
It's like these two really smushy pads that are together and it's great for,
it's almost like standing on a stability ball.
Right.
You stand on them and they're all mushy and you got to kind of use all your
stabilized.
No,
I've never used it.
Dustin runs,
Dustin runs on it.
Yeah.
I mean literally just sprints on it just does left.
Right.
Left,
right,
left,
right all day long.
He does upper body too.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
he had like some ankle issues and that,
that corrected it for him.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
So no,
he's,
he's somebody who um,
you know,
literally like we talked about my gym.
Dustin showed up
one day,
didn't even call me.
Uh,
it was before the Makowski fight.
He showed up at my gym one day and started taking classes.
I don't even know who he was.
Wow.
I had no idea what he had come in like two years before that when he was with
Duke,
when he was,
when he was a dude,
he came in and visited,
like did a class.
Then he came back in and did a class and I was like,
are,
he's still with UFC?
He's like,
yeah,
I got a fight coming up.
He said,
will you train me?
And I said,
sure.
I said,
that's fine.
Uh,
so we train them for it.
I was actually in Italy with Kevin for bellatore guest onto one.
Cornered him when he fought my cops.
I saw you out there in Toronto.
Yeah.
That first fight.
And literally that first camp,
he and I didn't do a single pad session.
He,
all he did was classes.
That was it.
That's how humble he is.
He didn't come in.
I'm a UFC guy.
I'm this and that and that's what I'm looking for him.
And I worked a little bit,
we did a little,
I was going to corner her hand.
Uh,
Carrie and obviously knew he was going to be cornering Kevin.
so I went up there with him,
so I started working a little bit together.
But it's such a great guy,
man.
Good vibes from Dustin Ortiz.
Yeah,
it seems like a really great guy.
And he's got like six goddamn lungs,
like heels just never get tired.
He's one of those guys,
I won 25 or I'm a feather way.
But you can spar like 20 rounds with a guy and he will not stop coming at you.
Yeah.
Well with this,
when this past weekend when,
so who doe beat Dj that way class just opened wide up.
Yeah.
That's,
that's what happens when something like that happens.
It happened with Chris Weidman beat Anderson Silva when the,
the undefeatable champion gets beat and then all of a sudden contenders will
rise.
And so there's a an interesting time for everybody at one 25 it's just such a
hard week class to find elite fighters.
Yeah.
And you know,
I've,
I've talked to Bella tour about it cause I've had other people out,
they have no interest in it.
None,
no one interest in 25 there.
They're debating how long they want to keep 35 really getting really
interesting.
But they don't do women,
uh,
in kickboxing under one 25,
you know,
they won't go near it and they don't do women over one 45 and they don't want
any men.
They don't have any men.
You've never seen a man kickbox for Bella tour less than 145 pounds.
Yeah,
it's never happened.
Is that because they're worried about power?
I think they're just worried about marketability.
Yeah.
But that's the thing is like the bigger people hit harder,
kinda more exciting to watch.
Absolutely.
Well,
listen gentlemen,
this has been fun.
It's always fun.
It's fun.
This time I didn't talk last time.
I got a lot of shit for not talking.
Last time you talked a little,
a little,
a little bit.
People who give you shit.
Just everybody.
Oh,
I want you to tell him like,
tell him to shut the fuck up.
It wasn't,
it wasn't about me.
It was about Kevin and guest.
Thank you for having won.
Oh my pleasure.
Anytime.
Listen,
I think what you're doing is really awesome.
I love the fact that you're competing in three different sports,
and the fact that you're doing it at the highest level,
it's,
it's really inspiring and it's interesting and it's very compelling,
you know,
and you're doing it at an awesome way.
Like I keep,
I plan on,
keep doing it and I went as far as long as I can.
So I just go.
So May.
But
yeah,
man,
I'm,
I'm having fun.
I love fighting.
I've been doing this.
I was 12 years old,
so I like to stay busy.
So anything that I can do,
if I can do more tie,
if I can do kick boxing,
if I can do them in May,
I'll,
I'll do it all at night.
And a CSA,
Jim on Instagram is just CSA.
Jim Correct.
At CSA,
Jim Instagram,
Facebook and Twitter.
And dream killer,
underscore Bolanos and spell belongs for the o l a man.
That was beautiful.
Yeah.
Thank you gentlemen.
Thank you.
I'm fine.
Thank you
man.
Okay.